Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行通过Airbnb会更美好。现在，你可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大及其许多当地的小众好去处。我曾在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。在第一年，剧组给我安排了一个住所。第二年，我想，嘿，不管那个制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
我可以拿着它去更像是一个社区的地方找我自己的住处，你知道吗？是的，我照做了，我租了一个Airbnb，一个小公寓，窗户正对着一个公园，太棒了。我很喜欢房东，在那儿住了两个月。哇。是的，而且离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的觉得我在那里过上了另一种小生活。我在想加拿大的落基山脉地区，那里有湖泊和阿尔伯塔落基山脉。我不知道，感觉如果你能在那里找到一间温馨的小木屋。你知道我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园。
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. So, you're hosting the family barbecue this week, but everyone knows your brother is the grill guy, and it's highly likely he'll be backseat barbecuing all night. So be it. And press even the toughest of critics
听着，也许你应该为你的下一次冒险考虑一下Airbnb。我是说，我们超爱它。超爱。所以，这周你要主持家庭烧烤，但人人都知道你哥哥是烧烤达人，而且很有可能他整晚都会在旁边指手画脚。那就这样吧。甚至能征服最挑剔的评论家
with freshly prepared Canadian barbecue favorites from Sobeys. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of BFF stories.
用来自Sobeys的精心准备的加拿大烧烤精选。我是詹娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是好朋友。现在我们为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们将深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后花絮以及大量的闺蜜故事。
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hey there. Hi everybody. Happy Wednesday. Happy Wednesday. How are you today? I'm good. Yeah.
我们是办公室辣妈 6.0。大家好。嗨，各位。周三快乐。周三快乐。你们今天好吗？我很好。是的。
I'm feeling good. Feeling good. Yeah. You know what I'm gonna do later? What? I am going to buy cheese at one of my favorite places to get cheese. Of all the things I thought you were gonna say,
我感觉很好。感觉不错。 yeah。你知道我等会儿要做什么吗？什么？我要去我最喜欢买奶酪的地方买奶酪。在我猜你想说的事情里，
that did not pop in my mind. I love, I love a cheese board. Why are you making a cheese board? Because my sisters are visiting. Oh, okay. That's lovely. I thought, you know, I wanna set out a little something they can nibble on after a travel day.
这个完全没在我脑子里出现。我喜欢，我喜欢奶酪拼盘。你为什么要做奶酪拼盘？因为我姐姐们要来。哦，好吧。那太棒了。我想，你知道的，我想准备点小东西，让她们在舟车劳顿之后可以吃点零食。
My new favorite snack is slices of brie cheese on these like seeded Trader Joe's crackers. I mean, what's not to love? I know, and then I put a few berries on the side. This is my go-to snack. On the side, why not put it right on top? A berry? What was this reaction? A berry on top of some brie?
我新最爱的零食是在这些Trader Joe's带籽饼干上放上几片布里奶酪。我是说，这谁能不爱呢？我懂，然后我在旁边放了几颗浆果。这是我的首选零食。在旁边，为什么不直接放在上面呢？一颗浆果？这是什么反应？布里奶酪上面放浆果？
Am I saying something crazy here? An apple slice? Like a green apple slice on top of your brie, on top of your cracker? Sure. But a berry. Give me a raspberry on there. A raspberry? Why not? Maybe a cranberry?
我说什么疯狂的话了吗？一片苹果？比如在你的布里奶酪上、饼干上放一片青苹果？当然。但如果是浆果。给我来颗覆盆子。覆盆子？为什么不呢？也许来点蔓越莓？
A lady. Come on, I eat cranberries and cheese all the time. I brought some, look right here. Look at that, cranberries and cheese. Look at that. Okay. The sass we have started with this morning from both of us. Let's tell everyone what we're doing today.
女士。拜托，我一直在吃蔓越莓和奶酪。我带了一些，看这里。看那个，蔓越莓和奶酪。看那个。好吧。我们今天早上从一开始就互相开玩笑了。让我们告诉大家我们今天要做什么。
Well, we have a really fun Office Lady 6.0. We have not one, but two really fantastic guests on. We do. We got to catch up with the amazing office writing team of Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg. But before we get to those interviews, I was curious. What were we doing, Jenna, in April 2008 on the set of The Office? Because that is around the time when we filmed one of our guest today's most famous episodes.
嗯，我们有一个非常有趣的“办公室辣妈 6.0”。我们不仅有一位，而是有两位非常棒的嘉宾。没错。我们采访了了不起的《办公室》编剧团队吉恩·斯特普尼斯基和李·艾森伯格。但在我们进入采访之前，我很好奇。詹娜，我们在2008年4月《办公室》片场在做什么？因为那大约是我们拍摄今天其中一位嘉宾最著名剧集的时间。
And since I never delete an email, I can tell you. What? This all centers around the week we were doing. Can you guess it? What is one of their most famous episodes? Their most famous episode is probably Dinner Party. Yes, Dinner Party. First of all, I got an email from Joya at NBC.com. She wrote me and said, "'Hey Angela, we saw some dailies from Dinner Party. "'That episode is going to be fantastic, I can tell already. "'I have some questions for you to answer.
既然我从来不删邮件，我可以告诉你。什么？这一切都围绕着我们当时正在做的那周。你能猜到吗？他们最著名的剧集是什么？他们最著名的剧集可能是《晚宴》。是的，《晚宴》。首先，我收到了NBC.com乔亚的邮件。她写信给我说：“‘嘿，安吉拉，我们看到了《晚宴》的一些毛片。’‘那一集肯定会很棒，我一眼就能看出来。’‘我有一些问题需要你回答。’
"'Let me know if you can.' I responded, "'Hey, we're on location the whole time at this condo, so no computer for me. Can I do this next week? Plus we get home most nights at 10 p.m. and I go straight to bed.'" So we were working some late nights that week.
‘如果你能的话，请告诉我。’我回复道：‘嘿，我们一直在这个公寓的外景地，所以我没有电脑。我下周再做好吗？另外我们大多数晚上十点才到家，然后我就直接睡觉了。’所以那周我们工作到很晚。
I remember that. Next up in my digital clutter, I got an email from you. "'You were planning my baby shower. And I guess I had to come to set late because I had a doctor's appointment. And you sent me an email titled tea party exclamation point. And when I opened it up, it said this,
我记得那个。接下来在我的数字杂物里，我收到了你的一电子邮件。‘你在策划我的迎婴派对。’我想我那天得晚点去片场，因为我有医生预约。你给我发了一封题为“茶会惊叹号”的邮件。当我打开它时，上面写着，
lady, you get your wish. Your shower is going to be catered by Paddington's. Oh, the best tea house in Los Angeles that has now shut down. I know. They had the best tea house in Los Angeles that has now shut down. I know. They had the best chicken salad tea sandwiches on this earth. It was so, it was just a cute little spot too. And then you ended your email with, how big is the baby now?
女士，你的愿望实现了。你的派对将由帕丁顿餐厅承办。哦，洛杉矶最好的茶馆，现在已经关门了。我知道。他们有洛杉矶最好的茶馆，现在已经关门了。我知道。他们拥有世界上最好吃的鸡肉沙拉茶三明治。那真是一个可爱的小地方。然后你的邮件结尾是，宝宝现在有多大了？
Oh, next email was from Chris Haston, Kate's boyfriend. He was on the set of the dinner party taking pictures. And he sent me a really funny photo that he took of me and Rain between scenes in my big preggers belly. He said, here's one, I've got some more. Smiley face. And I have the picture. Okay. And lady, you and I were doing press for the show. We got an email from NBC Publicity saying, we would like to do a satellite media tour with Jenna and Angela for the return of the show. We got an email from NBC publicity saying, we would like to do a satellite media tour with Jenna and Angela for the return of the show.
哦，下一封邮件来自克里斯·哈斯顿，凯特的男友。他在《晚宴》片场拍照。他发给我一张非常有趣的搞笑照片，是我和雷恩在两场戏之间，挺着我的大孕肚拍的。他说，这是其中一张，我还有一些。笑脸。我有那张照片。好的。女士，你和我当时正在为该剧做宣传。我们收到NBC公关部的一封邮件，上面写着：我们想为该剧的回归与詹娜和安吉拉进行一次卫星媒体巡回采访。我们收到NBC公关部的一封邮件，上面写着：我们想为该剧的回归与詹娜和安吉拉进行一次卫星媒体巡回采访。
Oh, because it was the return after the big break of the writer's strike that year, yeah. And it was going to be for dinner party. Oh, boy. You and I were going to start at 7 AM and go till 10 AM talking about the show. OK. Next email was from me to you.
哦，因为那是当年编剧大罢工大休息之后的回归，对吧。而且那是为了《晚宴》。哦，天哪。你和我将从早上7点一直聊到上午10点，谈论这部剧。好吧。下一封邮件是我发给你的。
I guess your mom had sent me these fuzzy flip-flops. So I sent you a picture and I said, please pass this pic onto your mom. A thank you card is on the way. I love my flips. Oh. I was very pregnant in the picture. Finally, Greg sent out an email to the cast and crew.
我想你妈妈送了我这些毛绒人字拖。所以我给你发了一张照片，我说，请把这张照片转达给你妈妈。感谢卡正在路上。我喜欢我的拖鞋。哦。我在照片里怀孕很明显。最后，格雷格向演员和剧组发了一封电子邮件。
He said he would like to do a farewell for Kent Subornak. Greg had gotten him a Rolex and had engraved on the back, Kent, good times. Love, the office. Oh, that's so lovely. There's a little picture into our lives the week we filmed Dinner Party. Well, we talked to Jean and Lee a lot about Dinner Party.
他说他想为肯特·苏博纳克举办一场告别会。格雷格给他买了一块劳力士，并在背面刻上了：肯特，美好时光。爱你的，办公室。哦，太美妙了。这是我们拍摄《晚宴》那周生活的精彩一瞥。嗯，我们和吉恩和李聊了很多关于《晚宴》的内容。
We did. And it's a good convo. They are so interesting to talk to. Their point of views about all of it. Oh my gosh, I loved it. So you guys, Jean and Lee joined the office in season two and they wrote the biggest hit episodes of the show. That's right. They wrote The Fight, The Secret, Michael's Birthday, The Convention, Traveling Salesman, The Return, Women's Appreciation, and Dinner Party, Job Fair, Weight Loss, The Surplus, New Boss, The Lover, Scott's Todd's, and the cover-up. They also directed Michael Scott Paper Company and The Lover,
是的。而且这是一次很好的对话。和他们聊天非常有趣。他们对这一切的观点。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。所以各位，吉恩和李在第二季加入了《办公室》，他们写了这部剧最热门的剧集。没错。他们写了《打架》、《秘密》、《迈克尔的生日》、《大会》、《旅行推销员》、《回归》、《妇女赞赏日》和《晚宴》、《招聘会》、《减肥》、《盈余》、《新老板》、《情人》、《斯科特的托兹》和《掩盖》。他们还导演了《迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司》和《情人》，
and they made cameos as Gino and Leo from Vance Refrigeration. And, you know, in addition to their work on The Office, they also co-created, wrote, and executive produced HBO's Hello Ladies with Stephen Merchant. It's great. Yeah. And they worked on other series like Trophy Wife. They worked on Bad Teacher, both the movie and the television
他们还在《万斯制冷公司》里客串了吉诺和利奥。而且，你知道，除了在《办公室》的工作之外，他们还与斯蒂芬·莫昌特共同创作、编写并执行制作了HBO的《Hello Ladies》。非常棒。是的。他们还参与了其他剧集，如《特劳比妻子》。他们参与了《坏老师》的电影和电视
show, and Smilf. And look, they've gone on both to be showrunners and written on several TV shows and movies separately, but they reunited in 2023 to co-create Jury Duty. Oh, it's so good. It's so good. It's a critically acclaimed miniseries. It won a Peabody Award for its innovative blend of comedy and reality storytelling. Well, listen, we just love this interview. We kind of just went through their episodes.
节目，以及《Smilf》。看，他们后来都成为了节目统筹，并分别在几部电视剧和电影中担任编剧，但他们在2023年重新聚首，共同创作了《陪审团义务》。哦，太棒了。太棒了。这是一部广受好评的迷你剧。它因其对喜剧和现实叙事的创新融合而赢得了皮博迪奖。听着，我们太喜欢这次采访了。我们基本上就是回顾了他们的剧集。
And we also got some new insights into how the writing process worked on the show. So let's take a quick break. And when we come back, it's Jean and Leigh. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you see that hilarious Saturday Night Live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where like in order to trick men into taking care of themselves, they made a medical clinic that is like a podcast, like a Dude Bro podcast. Oh my gosh, it's so funny but it's also because it's kind of true men are often reluctant to take the time to
我们还深入了解了该剧的编剧过程是如何运作的。所以让我们稍作休息。当我们回来时，就是吉恩和李了。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。女士，你看到了他们关于男性健康和心理健康的搞笑周六夜现场小品吗？为了诱使男性照顾自己，他们开了一家像播客一样的医疗诊所，就像一个老铁播客。哦天哪，太搞笑了，但这也是因为这有点真实，男人往往不愿意花时间
dig into their mental health I've got a stat for you six million men in the US suffer from depression every year and it's often undiagnosed so listen if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world, we would like to encourage you to talk to someone. A friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you want to give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise.
关注他们的心理健康。我有一个数据要告诉你，美国有六百万男性每年都饱受抑郁症的困扰，而且经常没有被诊断出来。所以听着，如果你是一个男人，正感受到世界的沉重，我们想鼓励你和某人聊聊。一个朋友，一个爱人，一个治疗师。也许你想试试BetterHelp。作为全球最大的在线心理治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以为你提供各种专业领域的心理健康专业人士。
Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Oh, this is it. The day you finally ask for that big promotion. You're in front of your mirror with your Starbucks coffee. Be confident, assertive, remember eye contact, but also remember to blink, smile,
通过BetterHelp倾诉心声。我们的听众在BetterHelp.com斜杠office ladies可以享受首月九折优惠。网址是BetterHelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠office ladies。哦，就是这个。你终于要开口要求大升职的那天了。你站在镜子前，手里拿着星巴克咖啡。要自信、果断，记得有眼神交流，但也别忘了眨眼、微笑，
but not too much. That's weird. What if you aren't any good at your job? What if they demote you instead? Okay. Don't be silly. You're smart. You're driven. You're gonna be late if you keep talking to the mirror. This promotion is yours. Go get them. Starbucks. It's never just coffee.
但别笑得太夸张。那就太奇怪了。万一你工作其实并不好呢？万一他们反过来降职呢？好吧。别犯傻了。你很聪明。你很有动力。如果你一直对着镜子说话，就要迟到了。这次升职是你的囊中之物。去拿下他们吧。星巴克。绝不仅仅是咖啡。
Hello! Hi, Gene and Lee! Hey, guys! Hello! Welcome to Office, ladies! We're so thrilled to have you here today. This is so fun. Gene, I haven't seen you in forever.
大家好！嗨，吉恩和李！嘿，伙计们！大家好！欢迎来到Office ladies！我们非常高兴今天能请到你们。这太有趣了。吉恩，我感觉好久没见到你了。
Lee, the last time I saw you, we ran into each other at the same dinner spot. That is right. Years ago. Lovely, lovely meetup. I haven't seen you guys in so long. I mean, Lee, I do have a Nuve bed cover on my bed. We'll get to that.
李，我上次见你，还是我们在同一个餐厅偶遇的时候。没错。那是多年前的事了。多么美好、温馨的重逢啊。我真的好久没见你们了。我是说，李，我的床上的确铺着一条Nuve床罩。我们待会儿会聊到这个。
I'm very excited to discuss. That you sent me. And Gene, I said this before we got on the mic, you look exactly the same to me. So I don't know what kind of magic potion. Bless your heart. It's called a filter. That's my line.
我非常期待讨论这件事。是你寄给我的。还有吉恩，我在我们开麦前就说过了，你在我眼里一点都没变。所以我不知道这是什么神奇的药水。承蒙夸奖。这叫滤镜。那是我的台词。
Oh, it's called a filter. Jenna's my line. It's called a filter. Jenna, why don't you kick us off with the first question? Well, you know, we normally ask people how they got their job on the office. And that is one of our questions. But we want to back it up and ask, how did you two meet and become writing partners? Do you want to take this? We met on the not on the set, but on the office of the film Be Dazzled Harold Ramis, who was a director, obviously, on the office as well. And Lee was an office PA. And I was an intern. I just moved to LA and I think we had just moved to LA a few months before that. And we became friends and we didn't immediately start writing together. But we were friends and both wanted to be writers.
哦，这叫滤镜。珍娜，那是我的台词。这叫滤镜。珍娜，你为什么不以第一个问题开启我们的对话呢？嗯，你知道的，我们通常会问别人是怎么得到《办公室》的工作的。这也是我们的问题之一。但我们要追溯一下，问问你们两个是怎么认识并成为搭档编剧的？你想接话吗？我们是在电影《迷魂阵》的片场——不对，不是片场，而是在办公室认识的，导演当然是哈罗德·雷米斯，他后来也导演了《办公室》。当时李是办公室制作助理。而我是一名实习生。我刚搬到洛杉矶，我想我们大概在那几个月前刚搬到洛杉矶。我们成了朋友，并没有立刻开始一起写作。但我们是朋友，而且都想成为编剧。
I think you were writing drama at the time, right? I was. I was writing very serious drama at the time. Very serious drama. Please elaborate. There's only one kind of drama that's very serious. Give us a nugget. The first show that I ever got hired on was JAG. The Military Courtroom Drama. YeahG, the military courtroom drama. Yeah, yeah.
我记得你当时在写正剧，对吧？是的。我当时在写非常严肃的正剧。非常严肃的正剧。请详细说说。只有一种正剧是非常严肃的。给我们透露一点内幕吧。我受雇加入的第一部剧是《JAG：军法处》。军事法庭正剧。对，JAG，军事法庭正剧。对，对。
That's pretty serious drama. That is high stakes. And then I was fired, I think like maybe four weeks in, maybe six weeks in. Were you given a reason for your firing? Were you just not dramatic? Where to begin? Well, I was so intimidated by,
那确实是相当严肃的正剧。那风险太高了。然后我被解雇了，我想大概是四周左右，也可能是六周后。他们给你解雇的理由了吗？是因为你不够戏剧化吗？从何说起呢？嗯，我当时被吓得够呛，
I was like, how do these people write military courtroom stuff? I basically just Googled all the acronyms so that my scripts would look like I was in the military and had been a lawyer in the military. Then the first note I got was they couldn't follow anything because I had all these acronyms that they didn't know existed. It was not a, respectfully to anyone who worked on that show, I did not find it, now with the benefit of hindsight, it was not a particularly well-run show.
我就想，这些人是怎么写出军事法庭那种东西的？我基本上只是把所有的缩写都谷歌了一遍，好让我的剧本看起来就像我在军队里待过，而且还在军队当过律师。然后我收到的第一个反馈就是他们什么也看不懂，因为我用了所有他们根本不知道存在的缩写。那部剧，对所有在那部剧工作过的人表示敬意，我觉得现在回过头来看，它并不是一部运营得特别好的剧。
I don't think it really supported or lifted up young voices. And also to be fair to them, I probably was not quite the right fit for it based on where my career went from there, from that moment. Yes. Yeah. So you guys started writing together,
我不觉得它真的很支持或提拔年轻的声音。而且公平起见，从我后来从那一刻起的发展轨迹来看，我大概也确实不太适合那部剧。是的。没错。所以你们开始一起写作，
and was The Office your first job as writing partners? We sold a pilot to Fox a few months before we got on The Office. And that became our sample that Greg read and Terry Weinberg and all the folks at Reveille had read. And that was basically, we decided to write a show loosely based on us. And we decided to not make it characters named Lee and Gene who were losers who lived together who were codependent writers. So we basically took all of that except changed their names to Lonnie and Gordo and made them magicians.
《办公室》是你们作为编剧搭档的第一份工作吗？我们在加入《办公室》几个月前向福克斯卖出了一部试播集。那成了我们的样片，格雷格读过，特里·温伯格和雷维尔的所有人也都读过。基本上，我们决定写一部大致根据我们自己改编的剧。我们决定不把主角取名为李和吉恩，他们不是住在一起、互相依附的失败编剧。所以我们基本上采用了所有这些设定，只是把他们的名字改成了朗尼和戈多，并把他们设定成了魔术师。
But everything else was the same. They were codependent losers who lived together. And that became a sample that got us hired on the office. And maybe also became Leo and Gino. We don't have a lot of range. It goes from Leo and Gino to Lonnie and Gordo to Leo and Gino. So when you guys came in to meet on the office, did you meet with Greg? Because a lot of people have shared with us their first meetings with Greg and I'm so curious if you had one.
但其他一切都一样。他们是住在一起、互相依附的失败者。那成了让我们得以进入《办公室》的样片。也许还变成了利奥和吉诺。我们的戏路真的很窄。从利奥和吉诺到朗尼和戈多，再到利奥和吉诺。所以当你们来面试《办公室》时，你们见到了格雷格吗？因为很多人都跟我们分享过他们第一次见格雷格的经历，我非常好奇你们有没有过这样的经历。
We met with Terry first and then we met with Greg and we met him in like Westwood, I think. Yeah, like a coffee shop in Westwood. And in my mind, I didn't know what he looked like, but I thought he'd be wearing a cowboy hat. I think because of King of the Hill or something. I don't know why. I was like, he doesn't look anything like what I expect him to look like. And our agent told us, you know, it'll probably be a long meeting.
我们先是见了特里，然后见了格雷格，我们在韦斯特伍德的一个地方见的面，我想是的。对，就像韦斯特伍德的一家咖啡馆。在我脑海里，我不知道他长什么样，但我以为他会戴着牛仔帽。我想可能是因为《山丘之王》之类的原因吧。我不知道为什么。当时我就想，他长得跟我预期的完全不一样。我们的经纪人告诉我们，你知道的，这可能会是一场很长的会议。
He does long meetings. And it was. It was a couple of hours, two to three hours. That is what we have heard from folks. And that the conversation goes kind of all over the place. Yeah. No, he's very thoughtful. You got a sense of how his brain worked.
他总开很长的会。确实如此。持续了几个小时，两到三个小时。这就是我们从其他人那里听说的。而且谈话内容可以说是天马行空。对。不，他非常细心。你能感受到他的大脑是如何运转的。
And nothing gets past him. And he has a lot of questions. and he had a notebook with him. Lee said something about us writing from theme. Which wasn't even true. Yeah, it was something we had heard and like we kind of parroted it, parroted it and Greg got really excited and uh and pulled, he's like, look I just wrote that in my notebook right from theme. I remember that. No, no, no, it was actually like his notebook is notebook was like, it's what I imagine the Unibomber's notebook would have looked like. It was really like, every page was just filled. And, and Harold Ramis had always talked about
而且没有什么能逃过他的眼睛。他有很多问题。他还随身带了一个笔记本。李说了一些关于我们根据主题进行创作的话。这甚至都不是真的。对，那只是我们听过的一句话，然后我们就像鹦鹉学舌一样重复了出来，格雷格变得非常兴奋，呃，然后拿出了，他说，看，我刚刚把这个记在笔记本上了，根据主题创作。我记得那件事。不，不，不，实际上他的笔记本，他的笔记本简直就像，我想象中的大学炸弹客的笔记本会有的样子。真的就是，每一页都写得满满当当。而且，哈罗德·雷米斯以前总是谈论
writing from theme, Gina and I, I would say, had not up until that point written from theme. And so he's like, what did you learn from Harold Ramis? What did you learn from Harold Ramis? I said, what did we learn from Harold? Like, I was like, how to smoke weed? Like I was so, and I said, Harold always writes from theme and Greg's eyes lit up. And then he flipped to the page and in all block letters on the top,
根据主题写作，吉恩和我，我得说，在那之前并没有根据主题写作。所以他说，你从哈罗德·雷米斯那里学到了什么？你从哈罗德·雷米斯那里学到了什么？我说，我们从哈罗德那里学到了什么？就像，我当时在想，怎么抽大麻？我当时太，然后我说哈罗德总是根据主题写作，格雷格的眼睛一下子亮了。然后他翻到那一页，上面顶端全是大写字母写着
it said theme is important. Yeah. Which I think is a very funny thing to see. Can you share with our listeners, what does it mean to write from theme? Writing from theme is like, you want to explore jealousy. You want to explore a mother daughter dynamic. You know, it's the haves and the have nots.
主题很重要。对。我觉得这真的是一件很好笑的事情。你能和我们的听众分享一下，根据主题写作到底意味着什么吗？根据主题写作就像是，你想探讨嫉妒。你想探讨母女关系。你知道，这就是富有者和贫穷者的区别。
It's kind of like writing from an idea and then writing from character would be like, oh, I think it'd be really funny if there was a character who was the manager of an office. And then he could be funny because of X, Y and Z. I would say Seinfeld has no theme. Seinfeld is just purely character comedy. Mm hmm. Okay. That is so interesting to me. And it made it into Greg's book. Spiral that he carries around. But then you guys actually joined the staff in season two. Right? Yeah. I mean, we were, when we were living together, we would,
这有点像先从一个概念出发进行写作，而从角色出发则会是，哦，我觉得如果有一个角色是一家办公室的经理，那一定非常搞笑。然后他就可以通过X、Y和Z来变得搞笑。我要说《宋飞正传》没有任何主题。《宋飞正传》纯粹是角色喜剧。嗯哼。好吧。这对我来说太有趣了。而且它还真的写进了格雷格随身携带的那个螺旋笔记本里。但后来你们确实在第二季加入了剧组，对吧？对。我的意思是，当我们住在一起的时候，我们会，
first we watched the British office and we were huge fans of that. And then we saw season one and we were huge fans of that. We were really impressed at how, how you guys pulled it off because we did not, like everyone else, we did not have high expectations for the American version because we love the British one so much. And I mean and how could it be good? And we saw the pilot actually, right? Yeah. Yeah. And not even like the final cut, we had a friend who worked at NBC who showed us the pilot. We couldn't believe it. And then we watched the first season, you know, every
首先我们看了英国版的《办公室》，我们是它的超级粉丝。然后我们看了第一季，我们也是它的超级粉丝。我们对你们是怎么把这事搞定的印象极其深刻，因为我们和所有人一样，对美国版本并没有抱太大期望，因为我们太喜欢英国版了。我的意思是，怎么可能会好看呢？而且我们实际上看了试播集，对吧？对。对。甚至都不是最终剪辑版，我们有个在NBC工作的朋友给我们看了试播集。我们简直不敢相信。然后我们每周都看
week. And it was like six episodes. And it was just fantastic. I mean, we couldn't believe it. Then after we met with Greg, we got a call from our agent and we were offered the office with no guarantee of that we'd be able to write a script just I think it was like eight episodes or something. It was six episodes for the office with like six backup scripts. Yeah, like if you counted the number of writers, it felt like pretty we were gonna be one of the backup scripts. Yeah. And then it were a full season on an animated show on Fox. One of those animations and American Dad, which is American on for 30 years.
第一季。只有六集。简直棒极了。我是说，我们简直不敢相信。后来在我们和格雷格会面后，我们接到了经纪人的电话，我们得到了《办公室》的offer，并没有保证我们一定能写一剧本，我想大概是八集左右吧。那是《办公室》的六集，外加大概六个备用剧本。对，如果你数一下编剧的数量，感觉我们很可能会变成备用剧本之一。对。然后福克斯的一部动画剧有一整季的合同。其中一部动画是《美国老爹》，这部动画已经播了30年了。
So you had to pick American Dad, which had a long, long like shelf life possibilities, right? Or kind of take a risk on this show that only had a six episode pick up for the first season. And there was one more. There was one more show in the midst. You remember, Gene said a John Stamos show that only had a six episode pick up for the first season. And there was one more. Well, there's one more show in the midst. Do you remember, Gene? So the John Stamos show? Jake in Progress.
所以你必须选择《美国老爹》，它有着很长很长的续订可能性，对吧？还是说要在一部第一季只预定六集的剧上冒个险？当时还有一个。还有另一部剧在考虑范围内。你还记得吗，吉恩说的是那部约翰·斯塔莫斯的剧，第一季也只预定了六集。当时还有一部剧。好吧，还有另一部剧也在候选名单里。你还记得吗，吉恩？所以那部约翰·斯塔莫斯的剧是？《发展中》。
That's right. With John Stamos. That's right. Yeah. Real sliding doors moment for us. You know, even though... Guys, you had three offers to choose from. I mean, we know how talented you guys are, but that is not usual for writers to have, like, three different job offers
没错。由约翰·斯塔莫斯主演。没错。对。对我们来说真是个「滑动门」时刻。你知道，尽管……伙计们，你们当时有三个offer可以选。我的意思是，我们知道你们有多才华横溢，但对于编剧来说，在新的电视季开始时
at the beginning of a new television season. Well... That's kind of rad. This was after five years of abject failure. So, you know... This was your year. The year before we got hired on The Office, and, Gene, you can correct me on the number.
能拿到三个不同的工作机会可并不常见。好吧……这简直太酷了。这是在我们经历了五年的绝对失败之后才得到的……所以，你知道的……这是属于你们的一年。在我们被《办公室》录用前的那一年，吉恩，你可以纠正我的数字。
I don't like to talk about money because it's tacky, but Gene declared, I believe believe $8,000 in earnings the year before he was hired on the office. Yeah, I think it was like 7000. Yeah, but I remember my account was like, Okay, let me get your tax returns from last year. It's like taxes. Never paid taxes. And then so, you know, it was not even a question, even though it was gonna be a guaranteed full season of this other show that had been running for a long time. We didn't even hesitate.
我不太喜欢谈论钱，因为那样显得很俗气，但吉恩申报过，我记得在他被《办公室》录用前的那一年，他的收入是8000美元。对，我想大概是7000美元吧。对，但我记得我的会计说，好吧，让我看看你去年的纳税申报单。就像是报税。从来没交过税。然后呢，所以，你知道的，这甚至都不是个问题，尽管另一部已经播了很久的剧能保证有一整季的稳定合同。我们甚至连犹豫都没有。
We knew we wanted to be on The Office, even though it was only gonna be six episodes. It was a no-brainer. And then your very first episode was The Fight. And, you know, I was looking up the best Jim Dwight pranks, and this opener is listed in every list where people love this prank where Jim puts Dwight's desk in the bathroom. But it's so funny. Fans love it. Time Magazine did a list of all the
我们知道我们想加入《办公室》，尽管它只有六集。这是毫无疑问的。然后你们的第一集就是《打架》。你知道的，我当时在查吉姆和德怀特最好的恶作剧，每个榜单上都有这个开场，大家都喜欢这个恶作剧，吉姆把德怀特的办公桌搬到了洗手间里。但这太搞笑了。粉丝们爱死它了。《时代》杂志曾做过一个榜单，盘点了所有
best Jim pranks. That one makes it on there. What a fun episode to have be your first episode. It was I actually just I actually just rewatched it. Gene, it's really I was really proud of it. It was really it was very it was fun. It was so you know, we wrote that episode the entire first season of the I would say, like maybe the first season to season three, I was convinced we were going to get fired, I think, like probably until maybe like maybe until dinner party, I thought like every and maybe even past dinner party. I just I was always waiting to be fired. Gene was and so when we wrote the fight Greg had pneumonia and so
everyone kind of got sent off to write their scripts and we kind of like we were sent off with like as little information as like one could be sent off with to write an outline and certainly for your first episode how to it had kind of jag vibes to it. And so we wrote this outline and we went to Greg's house to get notes, like, because Greg couldn't come into the office. He was that sick. Yeah. Pretending to be that sick.
Yeah, exactly. And so we went to Greg's house and I remember Greg teaching us about subtext because we were like, that like Jim and Pam, like Jim probably said something like, I really like you. He was like, hey, you might want to dial that back.
Sometimes when someone has an interest in someone else, they sometimes without saying it, you get a sense of how they feel. Like, oh, interesting, okay. That's why we're both single. And so then we were, and so then- I was like, you can like someone and not tell them? And so, we ended up doing a rewrite on the outline
and ended up writing the first route. But the entire time I was like, oh, they someone and not tell them. And so, you know, we ended up doing a rewrite on the outline and ended up writing the first draft. But the entire time I was like, oh, they're setting us up to fail. This is their excuse. We're gonna write a terrible draft of the script. And then everyone knows that we don't belong on the show and then we'll get fired. And then it was like, of course,
that's like where things are headed. But that did not happen. Did not happen. Fight is awesome. And you guys wrote so many great episodes before dinner party. Telling you, I'm letting you into our mind. Yeah, I will say I wasn't as worried that we're gonna get fired. But
I do remember, we wanted to leave the show early on. We called our agent we're like, we don't we don't like it here. We want to go everyone's mean to us. And he's like, uh huh. He's like, Are you an idiot? We have been offered a blind script by Fox. We saw that we saw that we saw Lottie and Gordo to to Fox and they offer us a blind script, which means that, you know, they would basically give us money without knowing what the idea was, but we'd have to come up with a story for them and a script. And it was for a lot less money than working on the office.
But yes, people were not nice to us initially. And we were intimidated. We did ask if we could leave. Who? Who wasn't nice to you? Well, it was so ironic because the people who weren't nice to me... Name the names or say departments. I'm going to tell you because they're our friends, which is so funny in retrospect,
because it's BJ and Paul. They're your friends now? They're my friends now, BJ and Paul, who I talk to all the time and see all the time. But at the time, I was, you know how they are. Like if you don't know them, you know, it's kind of, we were the new guys, right? And Jen also started when we did and she's so outgoing and so nice.
And, and I mean, she was very nice to us. And, but you know, kind of like the clicks had formed and we were the new kids. And we're just like, you know, we don't need this. We can go have a blind script deal at Fox. And so we called and our agent was like, uh-huh, uh-huh. But we're just basically like, you guys are done. Go make friends. Stop it.
Yeah, go make friends. Don't be weird. Yeah. Can you talk about being on set for that first episode when we were shooting the fight? What do you remember? I have two strong memories. Well, a few things. The first was we had never been on set before, I have two strong memories. Well, a few things.
The first was we had never been on set before and no one, Greg just really, I mean, he really empowered writers in an amazing way to produce their own episodes, to be in the production meetings, to be in the sound mixes, to be in the edit, all of it. And we learned so much from it and that was like grad school for us.
The first day, I don't know what the scene was, but we were shooting, and the camera missed something. And Gene and I ran in from the little, you know, Greg's office, we ran into set. I went up to the director and said, Hey, you missed the camera missed that thing. He was here. You know, I saw that too. Okay, great. Thanks, guys. And then we went back to the office to our little, you know, video village office. And then the next take, there's something else. We ran back to the set because we because we're on the
onset producers, the onset producers, like, we have to show our value. So we ran back in and we said, like, hey, you know, can you adjust this or whatever? He said, Oh, yeah, of course. I was planning on doing that to ran back to our thing. And then I think after the third time, someone came to see us, it was Ken Zbornak, who was the producer. He was like, Hey, guys, you can't you can can't do it on every take. We are seeing what you're seeing.
Like when the camera misses the thing, it's not like you guys are eagle-eyed that we didn't see it. So just, you gotta let the director have a little, it was also Ken Poppins who had directed the pilot. And he's so sweet and also so good at his job. Yeah. And didn't need us coming in, we just didn't know.
And so we were kind of instructed that like, give the director, give the actors, like the actors also know that maybe, didn't need us coming in. We just didn't know. And so we were kind of instructed that like give the director give the actors like the actors also know that maybe they did. They didn't quite get what they wanted. So like, let everyone have a little bit of space. Breathe a little free. So that was the first thing. And then the other thing was we're shooting the cold open, and Dwight's desk is missing. And they're starting kind of rehearsing it. Maybe it's the first take and Greg happens to come down.
And he says, why isn't there anything under his desk? There'd be like little, you know, like hole punch like little- Trash, right? Yeah, rubber bands, things. Lint and dust. And he's like, you guys didn't think of that? And also like, and I was like, oh my God, oh my God.
We're like so ill equipped to do this. How could we not have thought that there'd be like dirt under someone's desk if the desk was moved. So Greg had a set deck like ad stuff and I was like, what a genius. That is pretty genius. Yeah, in fact, I remember the last time I did see the episode, I remember thinking, oh, look, there's crap underneath his desk.
That's good. I don't remember that story. I remember thinking, oh, look, there's crap underneath his desk. That's good. I don't remember that story. I was like, is that us? That's so funny. One of my favorite details from that episode is the 10 rules of karate that hangs on the wall in the dojo, which I understand you guys wrote that list. And Lee, you have that poster. I think it's in my garage.
That poster was in our office for a long time. That was a real delight to write. So I did karate growing up, and I was in the Junior Olympics. No big deal. Hey. Hey. You were in the Junior Olympics for karate? I was, yeah.
Wow. I got my ass kicked by an Oklahoman, as I recall. But anyway, so like kind of like being in a dojo was a lot of my childhood. And so like when Greg said, like, hey, there's a list of rules. She did. I had a lot of fun with that. Do you guys have any other things that you took as keepsakes from your time on the office? Oh, like, hold on one second. Oh, I wonder what he's going to bring.
Lee is going to grab something. Now I said that, and now I don't know if I can find it. I have. Oh, I know what you're going. I know what it is. I have the mallard. Yeah. I have the mallard. Yeah, you have the mallard. Wait, I like literally. Do I use to spy with? Yeah. Oh, that's a good one. Where is it? Oh, that's so weird. It must have gone moved. You have to promise me you'll find it and take a picture of it.
I will. I will. Please. With the mallard, please. That's amazing. What about you, Gene? Did you take anything? No, I have nothing. I wish I had stolen a bunch of... That would be worth so much now. I have nothing. I know... I just have my memories and those are fading quickly. So soon I'll have nothing. Well, I think NBC is still selling stuff off so you could probably get something. Greg shared with us that he bought Pam's front reception desk from the NBC auction. Oh my God. No. Yes. And it's in his production.
It's in his production. No. Yeah. Yeah. I know. I mean, I want to go see it. I do, too. You have to go see it. Oh, that would be wild, Jenna, if you do. So your second episode was The Secret and it had that famous cold open, the up dog. It's so funny. I just watched it this morning. And when Michael can't deliver, when he goes around trying to do the up dog to everybody,
and then finally Dwight takes the bait and he can't remember how to finish it, his performance is so great. But Jenna and I were, we found out that that's sort of based on something that happened to you guys. Oh, so the year that I made $7,000, I made the money I made, it was from being a nanny and like going on vacation with this family that I knew. And the kids-
You traveled with them to watch the kids on their vacation. Yeah, exactly, exactly. I think I'd been fired, I was always getting fired as an assistant. I'd been fired and I went with them somewhere and one of the kids did it to me. Now, oh, and actually, that would happen a lot. You know, like one
of the other kids, you know, like, I was complaining about something and they're like, Oh, why don't you go call the Wambulance? And I would just any of those little things would, you know, oftentimes end up in the show. So up dog, they did to me and I was like, Oh, okay. Stored that away. And that's what it was. Just to continue on the theme of me being convinced that we were going to get fired. So the secret, for whatever reason, we fell behind in the writers room and we got like, we had to break the secret in like, I remember it was like me and Gene and Mike, Mike Schurr. And we broke it like in a day or something.
And it was a pretty big episode. Wow. And Gene and I went off to write it. I think we wrote it in like three or four days, which was way shorter than, but like we needed a draft because there was a table read and you know, whatever the thing was. We always thought we were being set up to fail.
Why did they do this to us? I was like, oh, of course. The great writer's room conspiracy. I also like now having been a showrunner, the idea that like all that Greg was thinking about was like, how to would like be staff writers and make his show worse. Yeah. What a weird decision. No, but so anyways, we got such a short amount of time to write it
that we were like, oh, we're we're screwed. And I remember calling Mike to say, can we do like on the board of the, uh, the writers when they're all that kind of the index barred through all the different storylines, our potential storylines and spring cleaning was one of them. And it was going to be like a big, you know, it could have potentially been its own episode. And I was like, can we take spring cleaning for the secret? We're desperate. And then he was like, okay, you can do it. And we're like, oh my God.
And so we put spring cleaning into the secret last minute because we just like needed something. We needed a beat story. You know, a lot more of it's in the super fan episode. It starts with like Dwight. He comes in with all of these different size trash bins and he's just unloading all these trash bins and he's whistling the song Tequila.
But when he gets to Tequila, he goes, spring cleaning. Na na na na na na na. So it definitely has a bigger presence in that version. That's really funny. I have a tangential story about Greg Daniels thinking that I was purposely tanking an episode of The Office. Oh.
So I don't know. Now when I'm hearing this, I'm like, is this all like a writer thing where like there's some neurosis in writers that makes them think that like people are conspiring to make their work bad? I don't know. So it was that episode, The Delivery, and there was this scene where Pam was supposed to be singing to baby Cece who wouldn't nurse. I was supposed to be saying things like,
in that way where you're talking to a baby, but you're saying like, you stupid little baby, I can't stand you and why won't you just nurse with your stupid little mouth and you're dumb crying. It was like something like that where I was supposed to be like kind of insulting the baby as like a coping mechanism for the fact that I was so tired and I couldn't nurse. And you guys, I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it.
Like I just did not have it in me to say mean things to this little newborn baby that they handed me on the set. And I tried and tried and tried. And it was the only time that Greg ever called my manager, my manager agents, they all called me on the phone and they were like, we just received a phone call from Greg Daniels. And he's very upset. Oh, my God. He said that you purposely did a bad job today because you didn't like the scene where Pam is singing to the baby. And I was like, what? I didn't.
And basically, it was just Greg calling to say that I was horrible. Basically, you were horrible in the scene. You were like so bad that the only thing I can come up with is that you are trying to sabotage this out of the episode. Yes, sabotage. So I had to go to Greg and be like, Greg, I honestly, it's just that this is beyond my range as an actor. Like I don't have it. I don't have it in me. And we set it up and he made me reshoot it. And he came to set and was like, trying to get me to do it. And
then after that, he's like, Okay, Jenna, I see you're really trying. We'll just change it. You can't do it. You can't do it. I said, Greg, I can't do it. I have to say, it's kind of a compliment to your acting that he thought you could do it and chose not to. I guess I'll take it as a compliment, but it's... That's wild. It's so nuts that, like, yeah. Can I say, I remember this so well.
So, in The Secret, there's a scene with you and John in the kitchen, and he says, I told Michael that I had a crush on you, but I don't anymore. And you say, so you'd be weird around me now. And you did this thing with your eyebrows. And I remember it's like this. It's like a micro act. It is like, and I remember it like when we I remember when we shot it when we were now now safely in our video village, where we didn't correct everything that was happening. And I was like, that's the best acting I'd ever seen.
Like, literally, it was incredible. Like, it was so small, it was so subtle, and it, like, I felt so much from it. It was just like, again, at that point, I guess we had learned a little bit of subtext. And just the scene of, like, how much was unspoken between the two of you, and what I was feeling from what you were emoting with just with your eyes. It was like it took my breath away. It was the first time. It was
the first time I worked on the show because it was also it wasn't a comedic scene and it was like just being comfortable in a scene that like was just about Jim and Pam and was like a proper romantic scene and the will they won't they of it and I was blown away by your acting. I didn't call your manager at the time and say that you did a great job, but I think I maybe told you at the time. I hope I did. Well, thank you so much. I appreciate it. I remember you sobbing, Video Village. Yeah. I had pulled a clip of my favorite scene from The Secret. It's in the break room. And it's when Michael has just found out that he's the only person who knows
that Jim has secret feelings for Pam, and he's trying to talk to Jim about it, even though Jim doesn't want to talk about it, and then Stanley walks in and he's good, can he listen to it? This is my favorite scene. Hey, what you getting? Um, good one with grape.
Ah, good stuff, good stuff. See the game last night? What's your game? Any of them. Yeah. So, uh, what's 411? Any updates on the, uh, the peace situation? I don't know any...
P-A-M, P-A-M. Okay. No, it's okay, we're talking code. What? What is? Listen, Stan, you know, how long does it take you to pick out a soda? I gotta take off, no. P.A. Okay. No, it's okay. We're talking code. What is? Listen, Stan, you know, how long does it take you to pick out a soda? I'm gonna take off, actually. All right.
Well, cool. Soliciting? Hmm? Peach iced tea. You're gonna hate it. There's so many things in that. And then Michael, for the rest of the episode, like puts his hair down like Jim drinks grape soda.
Yeah. Wonderful. I think that was a Steve improv. Peter, I see you're going to hate it. He seems so angry. It's so funny just him trying to be cool. Anytime he tries to be cool with Jim or with Ryan, it just makes me laugh. Yeah.
It's just very like dude bro, like love. Yeah. I wanted to ask you guys about Michael's birthday because we hardly ever went on location, you know, and then you have like this dojo in the fight and then Michael's birthday, we go to this ice rink. And I remember it was sort of a big deal. There was a stunt guy that did all these pirouettes and then it would cut to Oscar as remember it was sort of a big deal. There was a stunt guy that did all these pirouettes and then it would cut to Oscar
as if it was Oscar doing all of them. And I remember he came up to me and he wanted to teach me a trick. So like, this is whatever, this is a random thing that never made it in the episode. But Matt captured all this content of me skating with this guy that's supposed to look like Oscar who kind of tossed me and like held me in the air up high.
It, it lives somewhere. I don't know where, but that was such a fun episode. And of course, you know, Steve's wife, Nancy is in that one. Yeah. What memories do you have from that episode? I remember the suit that Michael was wearing. Like a birthday suit. It's like, so it's like shiny. It's pinstriped. Yeah, he's like so proud of it. And then also, he gets lifted up on the chair kind of like horror style. His head goes through the thing. And I remember there was actually like, Steve was like, I think
they went a little too high and like dust was coming down and stuff. Like, it was a quote unquote a stunt. I remember seeing Steve ice skate for the first time. Yeah, that like, oh, wow, that's kind of wild. What a cool thing that Michael Scott's great at something. Yeah. Yes. There's this great runner of Talking Heads in the episode where Michael is describing
his worst birthdays. Amazing. And he's comparing them to this birthday. And there's a third one that made it into the super fan episode. I asked Sam if he would pull these Talking Heads of Michael's worst birthdays. And there's a third one that made it into the super fan episode. I asked Sam if he would pull these talking heads of Michael's worst birthdays. When I was seven, my mother hired a pony and a cart to come to my house for all the kids.
And I got a really bad rash from a pony. And all the kids got to ride the pony, and I had to go inside, and my mother was rubbing cream on me for probably three hours, and I never came outside. And by the time I got out, the pony was already in the truck and around the corner. So that was my worst birthday.
而且我曾被一匹小马弄得满身红疹。所有的小孩子都去骑小马了，而我只能进屋，我妈妈可能给我抹了三个小时的药膏，我再也没出来过。等我出来的时候，小马已经在卡车上转过弯了。所以那是我的最糟生日。
When I was 16, I was supposed to go out on a date with a girl named Julie, but there was another Michael in the class that she apparently thought the date was with, so she went out with him on my birthday, and she got him a cake at the restaurant, and it wasn't even his birthday but I heard about it the next day in school so that was the worst birthday I think I ever had on my 20th birthday my supposed best friend Sam Ambrose ditched me for his twin sister's sweet 16 party. And that was my worst birthday.
在我16岁那年，我本该和一个叫朱莉的女孩去约会，但班上似乎有另一个迈克尔，她以为约会对象是那个人，所以在我生日那天她和那个人约去了，还在餐厅给他买了个蛋糕，那天甚至都不是他的生日，但我第二天在学校听说了这件事，所以那大概是我经历过的最糟糕的生日。在我20岁生日那天，我所谓的好朋友萨姆·安布罗斯为了他双胞胎姐姐的16岁成人礼派对把我给甩了。那也是我的最糟生日。
Until today. You know what's so funny? Sam Ambrose is a comedette. Our friend Sam Handel and Lauren Ambrose, the actors are married, so we named the character Sam Ambrose. But that's one of those examples where like, we spent probably like hours and hours trying to figure out how
直到今天。你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？萨姆·安布罗斯是个女喜剧演员。我们的朋友萨姆·汉德尔和演员劳伦·安布罗斯结婚了，所以我们把这个角色命名为萨姆·安布罗斯。但这就是那种例子，比如说，我们可能花了几个小时又几个小时去琢磨怎么
to do the talking head for Michael's worst birthday. And then Steve Carell improvised. Those things were like, hey, Steve, just do your worst birthday and just came up with those things and those end up in the episode. He's so incredible. These are the moments. Sometimes writers don't like actors and sometimes writers love actors. And this is one of those moments when it are the moments, though, you know, sometimes writers don't like actors and sometimes writers love actors. And this is one of those moments when it's just like, oh, wow, you made it better than we could. We're still gonna get the credit
为迈克尔的最糟糕生日拍摄面对镜头的独白。然后史蒂夫·卡瑞尔即兴发挥了。那种感觉就像，嘿，史蒂夫，就演你的最糟糕生日，然后他就即兴想出了那些内容，而这些内容最终进入了正片。他太不可思议了。这些就是那些时刻。有时候编剧不喜欢演员，有时候编剧爱演员。这就是其中一个时刻，虽说这些就是那些时刻，你知道的，有时候编剧不喜欢演员，有时候编剧爱演员。这就是其中一个时刻，感觉就像，哦，天哪，你把它改得比我们想的还要好。我们还是会署名
and you made the episode better and it's funnier and you solved it the best. ["Street Eaters Theme"] Craving an escape? The New BMO VI Porter MasterCard is your ticket to more. More perks. More points. More flights. More of all the things you want in a travel rewards card and then some.
而且你让这集更好看了，更搞笑了，你用最棒的方式解决了它。[街头食客主题曲] 渴望来一场逃离？全新的BMO VI Porter万事达卡带你解锁更多精彩。更多特权。更多积分。更多航班。更多你对一张旅行奖励卡的所有期待，甚至远超所期。
Get your ticket to more with the new BMO ViPorter MasterCard and get up to $2,400 in value in your first 13 months. Terms and conditions apply. Visit bmo.com slash ViPorter to learn more. I would love to ask you guys which character in the office that you found was your favorite to write for. I mean, obviously, I know Michael was like such an amazing character, but were there other characters that you would look forward to writing things for? There's definitely some
使用全新的BMO ViPorter万事达卡解锁更多精彩，在头13个月内获得价值高达2,400美元的回馈。受条款及细则约束。访问 bmo.com slash ViPorter 了解更多。我很想问问大家，在《办公室》里，你们觉得写哪个角色是你们的最爱？我的意思是，显然，我知道迈克尔是个如此惊艳的角色，但有没有其他角色，会让你们充满期待地为他们创作内容呢？绝对有一些
The Toby Pam stuff was small, but I was just rewatching it and like it's so Paul the way you guys both are for is amazing But just like a guy who is in love with like the love with, it's like the eighth story on the show. But he leaves, he's like, I need to go get a camera and then I want to get a picture of the two of us. And then she's like, oh, I don't have a camera. And then he's like, I don't even have a camera. And then he runs off.
托比和帕姆的戏份虽然不多，但刚才我一直在重看，保罗，你们俩的表现方式真是太棒了。就好像一个单恋着，那种单恋，这甚至算剧里的第八条故事线。但他要离开，他说，我得去拿个相机，然后我想拍一张我们俩的合影。接着她说，哦，我没有相机。然后他说，我甚至都没有相机。接着他跑开了。
That really made me laugh. The bench of actors was so deep. I don't know. I mean, there's amazing Ed stuff. I can't think of anyone I wasn't excited to write for. I mean, it just really depended, I guess, probably on the story or or whatever it was. It was just so fun. Yeah. You don't realize at the time, but like, you know, you're spoiled. You can. There's so many weapons
这真的把我逗笑了。演员阵容太深厚了。我不知道。我的意思是，埃德的表演非常精彩。我想不出有谁是我不期待为他写剧本的。我的意思是，这真的取决于故事本身，或者其他什么因素，或者无论是什么。总之太有趣了。是的。当时你并没有意识到，但你知道的，你被宠坏了。你可以。有那么多的王牌
you can go to, and that's not normal on a show. So it was endless. It was amazing. Was there ever anything that you pitched that never got to see the light of day that you're like, Oh, I wish we had gotten to write that one story. We worked really hard. There's a, we called it the premonition. Nose with Aaron. And it was she had this premonition that someone from the office on the drive home was going to get in a car accident and die. And she wouldn't let anyone leave. And then we just couldn't break it. We could not figure out like, well, yeah, it was it was basically that. But that, you know, somebody says that and like, most people roll their eyes because it's like, okay, this, you know, she's been
你可以打，这在一部剧里是不正常的。所以这是无止境的。这太棒了。有没有什么情节是你曾提出过但从未见天日，以至于让你觉得，哦，真希望我们当时写了那个故事？我们真的很努力。有一个，我们称之为预感。跟艾瑞尔有关的鼻子。大致是她有这样一种预感，办公室里的某个人在开车回家的路上会遭遇车祸身亡。而且她不让任何人离开。然后我们就是无法把这个情节理顺。我们怎么也想不通，嗯，对，基本上就是这样。但是，你知道的，有人这么说了，然后就像，大多数人都翻白眼，因为觉得，好吧，这个，你知道的，她之前
right before the seven before and then she's been right before. And so basically, the office is split, like Jim and Pam, like Pam won't leave and Jim wants to leave. And like, it basically was that like half the office believes that Aaron, what if Aaron's telling the truth and that are not telling the truth, but that if she can see the future, and then the other half doesn't. But it was just it kind of became one of those things where it was like, the premise of it was so fun and we got down the road on it,
之前已经猜中过七次了，而且她之前也猜中过。所以基本上，办公室分成了两派，比如吉姆和帕姆，帕姆不肯离开，而吉姆想走。基本上就是办公室的一半人相信艾瑞尔，如果艾瑞尔说的是真的，或者说不是说真的，而是她真的能预知未来，而另一半人不信。但这有点变成了那种情况，就是它的前提非常有趣，而且我们在这上面也推进了一段距离，
but we never quite, it wasn't a sauce like that. We never quite cracked it. I love that. And I do think that Pam would want to stay just based on the fact that Pam believes in ghosts. Yeah. And like Jim's like, why do you believe in ghosts? Who are you? All right. Gene and I also, we wrote a ton of talking heads.
但我们始终没有，它不像那样能自圆其说。我们始终没有完全搞定它。我喜欢这个。而且我确实觉得帕姆会想留下来，就凭帕姆相信有鬼魂这一点。对。然后吉姆就会说，你为什么相信鬼魂？你到底是谁？好吧。吉恩和我还写了大量的面对镜头独白。
I get on it. Some of them maybe got shot. Some of them didn't. I think all the writers had different, slightly like for Michael, it's like Michael is a circle and people had their own little lanes. It was all still within the character. I think we wrote the saddest, most pathetic version of him often. We had a lot of stuff with like Michael's, Michael went to his prom,
我来接上。其中一些可能被拍了。有些没有。我觉得所有的作家都有各自稍微不同的偏好，比如对迈克尔来说，迈克尔就像一个圆，每个人都有自己的小轨道。但这一切仍然在角色的设定之内。我觉得我们经常写出他最悲伤、最可怜的版本。我们有很多关于迈克尔的内容，比如迈克尔去参加了他的毕业舞会，
but he was the limo driver. And he was like playing he was like playing cards or like dice for the other limo drivers. And they convinced him to go in. And then there's another thing with Todd Pack. There's a lot of like, just Michael like went somewhere and like, he got beat up. It was in the papers. Yeah, yeah. But it was like, yeah, we shot it. Yeah, it's true, though, like, yeah. But it was like, yeah, we shot it. Yeah. It's true though, like different writers wrote different Michael's like Mike sure his Michael's
但他其实是加长轿车的司机。他在和别的加长轿车司机玩牌或者掷骰子。然后他们说服他进去了。然后还有一段关于托德·帕克的。有很多类似的情节，就是迈克尔去某个地方然后挨揍了。这上了报纸。对，对。但就像是，对，我们拍了。对，千真万确，不过，像是，对，对，我们拍了。对，千真万确，不过，就像，不同的编剧写出不同版本的迈克尔，比如迈克·舒尔写的迈克尔，
almost somebody the most noble version of Michael, like, you were just hoping he would like pull out a win, you would do the right thing. And then he did in his own weird way. But he did that. I feel like Mike wrote the best version of Michael, the best person. And like Mindy wrote Michael as kind of like, he was in love with Ryan and was trying to, I don't know what, but just was like, very into Ryan or Jim in some ways.
几乎是迈克尔最崇高、最高尚的版本，你知道，你只是希望他能反败为胜，做出正确的事情。然后他确实用他自己诡异的方式做到了。但他做到了。我觉得迈克写出了最好版本的迈克尔，最好的人格。而明迪笔下的迈克尔有点像是，他暗恋着瑞安，并试图，我不知道是什么，但就是对瑞安或者在某些方面对吉姆非常着迷。
But yeah, everyone kind of had a different Michael. That is fascinating. Oh, Jinx. You know, you guys wrote something for me that was so much fun to play, and I've never really, I don't really think I've ever told you how much fun I had doing it. It's in New Boss with Idris Elba, and Angela and Kelly clearly thinks like he's the bee's knees. And it's pouring rain, and I go and get that scarf, and we're like fighting to like give the scarf.
但是，是的，每个人都有点不同版本的迈克尔。太迷人了。哦，倒霉。你知道的，你们为我写的东西演起来太有趣了，而且我真的从来、我觉得我从来没有告诉过你们我演得有多开心。那是在《新老板》里，搭档伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴，安吉拉和凯莉显然觉得他帅呆了。外面下着倾盆大雨，我去拿了那条围巾，然后我们就像在抢着献上围巾。
And then I have this talking head, I have all this mascara that's streaming down my cheeks. And it was so much fun. I mean, I normally am just sort of the sour gal in the bad corner. And to just have that much fun to play in an episode. Anyway, I just loved it. I don't know if I ever thanked you guys for that great scene. It's really fun when a character is kind of, you think you know who someone is and then you find a new color on that character. It's always the most fun. I think like when we first got to the show,
接着我有这样一段面对镜头的独白，我的双颊流淌着厚厚的睫毛膏。这真的太有趣了。我的意思是，我通常只是角落里那个尖酸刻薄的女孩。能在一集里有这么开心的一次表演体验。总之，我太喜欢了。我不知道我有没有谢过你们写了这么棒的一场戏。当一个角色有点，你以为你很了解某个人，然后你在这个角色身上发现了新的特质，这真的非常有趣。这总是最有趣的。我觉得就像我们刚进剧组的时候，
I was so blown away by the way that the room was approaching Dwight. Cause I think Dwight like on the surface, you think he's like, oh, he's this guy. And he's like, he's robotic and he's anal. And he's like, all he wants to do is please Michael. And then it's like, oh, no, like Dwight, like the ladies love Dwight. A certain type of lady loves Dwight.
我对编剧组处理德怀特的方式感到无比震撼。因为我觉得德怀特表面上看起来，你会觉得他是那种人，他就像个机器人，而且强迫症。他只想取悦迈克尔。然后结果却是，哦，不，德怀特，女士们都爱德怀特。某种特定类型的女士就是爱德怀特。
And you know what I mean? And he loves like the music he loves. Like, I don't know. He was so much rounder as the character in such a great way than than I like imagined as a fan of like the first season. You guys wrote two of the first season. You guys wrote two of the cringiest episodes of The Office, one that people love to watch more than any episode, and one that sometimes people avoid when they rewatch.
你知道我的意思吗？而且他喜欢的音乐，我不知道。作为第一季的粉丝，我没想到这个角色的层次会这么丰富，棒极了。你们写了《办公室》里最尴尬的两集，其中一集大家比任何一集都爱看，而另一集大家重温时有时会选择跳过。
Yes. I know what you're talking about. We've gotten a lot of mail. There's one people are like, I have to skip it. I have to skip it. So of course, the first one is dinner party. My god, you guys, you wrote dinner party. People know every line. People know that episode.
是的。我知道你在说什么。我们收到了很多来信。有一集大家会说，我得跳过它。我得跳过它。所以当然，第一集就是《晚宴派对》。天哪，你们俩，你们写了《晚宴派对》。每个人都知道每一句台词。每个人都知道那一集。
It is so wild. That's an example of finding another color to our character. So the scene where Jim tries to leave Pam at the dinner party, that's like a, you know, because Jim was always noble and you know, you know, Jim and Pam, they love each other. But we all know in life, in reality, that things don't always go that way. And sometimes you have to be a little bit selfish. Mike sure never would have let Jim leave. But Leah and Gene were like, all right, we're
这太疯狂了。这就是在我们角色身上发现新特质的例子。所以吉姆试图在晚宴派对上抛下帕姆的那场戏，那就像是一个，你知道的，因为吉姆一向很高尚，而且你知道，吉姆和帕姆，他们深爱彼此。但我们都知道在生活中，在现实中，事情并不总是那样发展的。有时候你不得不自私一点。迈克·舒尔绝对不会让吉姆离开。但莉娅和吉恩觉得，好吧，我们
out of here. I'm bouncing. This is the arc of our not understanding subtext to overusing subtext, where it's like, all right, we're out of here. I'm bouncing. This is the arc of our not understanding subtext to overusing subtext, where it's like, there won't be another party, you know, or whatever. So we went the other way with it. But yeah, that's an example of showing another side of the character.
撤了。我要闪人了。这就是我们从不理解潜台词到过度使用潜台词的转变过程，就好像，不会再有另一个派对了吧，你知道的，诸如此类。所以我们反其道而行之。但是，是的，这就是展现角色另一面的一个例子。
Have you seen the Peacock super fan of Dinner Party? I have not. All of the scenes are just a little bit more. It's so fantastic. I mean, you know, I obviously like some of the episodes as they aired originally, that's how I want to remember them. But I think because we love Dinner Party so much, we went and watched the super fan one and it is, it's delicious.
你看过Peacock平台《晚宴派对》的超级粉丝版吗？我没看过。所有的场景都稍微多了一些内容。这太棒了。我的意思是，你知道的，我显然喜欢最初播出的那些集，那是我想要记住它们的方式。但我想因为我们太爱《晚宴派对》了，所以我们去看了超级粉丝版，它真的，太精彩了。
I remember the most painful moment maybe of my creative life was trying so hard to show the extended version because remember they were doing those that season. Super size. Super size. Super size. Yeah. And I know like it was just the timing wasn't right.
我记得我创作生涯中也许最痛苦的时刻，就是极力想要展示加长版，因为记得他们那个季度在做那些。超大版。超大版。超大版。对。而且我知道，那只是时机不对。
But I always thought the best version of Dinner Party was the one that was slightly. Like 27 minutes. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. 27 minutes. And that killed me that we had to cut stuff out. Well, you should go watch the super fan just like, you know, just for fun, because I think a lot of those moments that you loved
但我一直觉得《晚宴派对》最好的版本是那种稍微多一点的。大概27分钟。对。对，没错。27分钟。不得不删掉一些内容让我心痛不已。好吧，你应该去看看超级粉丝版，就当是，你知道的，为了好玩，因为我觉得很多你喜爱
and wanted in are back in. Can I tell a dinner party anecdote? Yes. Yes. So the secret we wrote in three days or four days and dinner party was the opposite. Gina, I were staying in New York together, obviously, and it was kind of like a break. So we had, I think, like a month off from the show between seasons and everyone was assigned a script.
并且希望保留的时刻又回来了。我能讲一个关于《晚宴派对》的轶事吗？可以。可以。所以《秘密》我们在三四天内就写完了，而《晚宴派对》则完全相反。吉恩和我当时一起住在纽约，显然，那就像是一个假期。所以我们有大概一个月的时间不用拍这部剧，介于两季之间，每个人都分到一个剧本。
And the room was competitive and like, you know, you wanted to kind of have like, you wanted to have the best episodes. So we worked really, really hard. We had some feature work we were supposed to be doing. And we spent, I think, three weeks writing Dinner Party. And we handed the script and we were really happy with it. We spent three weeks writing dinner party when we should have been working on a movie script. Yeah, people were paying us to write. Correct. Yeah, absolutely.
编剧室里充满了竞争，而且，你知道的，你很想拥有，你想要拥有最好的剧集。所以我们真的非常非常努力地工作。我们当时还有一些电影剧本的工作要做。我们花了，我想是三个星期来写《晚宴派对》。然后我们交出了剧本，对它非常满意。我们花了三个星期写《晚宴派对》，而当时我们本该在写一个电影剧本的。对，那是别人付钱让我们写的。没错。对，绝对是的。
So you basically, you know, you're sitting in the writer's room and the other writers are reading your script in front of you. And if you like a joke, you check it and if you don't, you kind of like mark an X and you hear people laugh or not laugh. And so you're just kind of like, you're sitting in the room as all of these people that you really like and respect. At this point, they're our friends, not our enemies. And we're sitting there, and you hear someone go, huh? And you're like, what page you on? What's that laugh?
所以你基本上，你知道的，你坐在编剧室里，其他编剧当着你的面读你的剧本。如果你喜欢某个笑话，你就勾一下，如果你不喜欢，你就会打个叉，然后你会听到大家笑或者不笑。所以你当时的心情大概就是，你坐在房间里，周围都是你非常喜欢和尊重的人。到了这个时候，他们是我们的朋友，而不是敌人。我们坐在那里，然后你听到有人发出“哼”的一声，你就会想，你看到第几页了？那个笑声是什么意思？
And you're just like desperate to hear like, you know, what people are responding to. Wait, I have to stop you because I never heard this before. Wait, so you sit around a conference table and you just like read it to yourself though, not out loud. Everyone's just like reading your script in the same room. That would give me heart palpitations. Oh, it's the worst.
然后你就会极其渴望听到，你知道的，大家对什么有反应。等等，我得打断你，因为我以前从没听过这个。等等，所以你们是坐在会议桌旁，然后自己默读，而不是朗读出来？每个人都在同一个房间里读各自的剧本？这会让我心悸的。哦，这简直是最糟糕的。
And so some people go to their office. Some people like sit on the couch. But you know it's all happening at the same time. They've all gone off to read it. Yeah, because we have to like, hey, everyone read dinner party. And then, you know, in 45 minutes, let's sit around the table and like, let's start talking about how we're gonna rewrite it or whatever.
所以有些人会回自己的办公室。有些人会坐在沙发上。但你知道这一切都在同时发生。大家都去读剧本了。是的，因为我们必须，嘿，大家读一下《晚宴派对》。然后，你知道的，在45分钟后，我们在桌旁坐下来，开始讨论我们该如何重写它之类的。
Oh, my gosh. Okay, go on, go on. It's so stressful. We're getting we're getting some laughs. But it's like, it's pretty tense. And then we also sent it into the network. And we get on a call. So the writers room, I was like, people seem to like it. But I was kind of disappointed by the reaction because like, I thought we'd done a nice job. So then we get on the phone with the network. So it's me, Greg and Jean are in Greg's office. And I can't remember who was on from the network and it's Hey, so we got
哦，天哪。好吧，继续，继续。这太让人紧张了。我们收到了一些笑声。但感觉，挺紧张的。然后我们把它发给了电视台。我们开了个电话会议。所以编剧室里，我当时觉得，大家似乎挺喜欢的。但我对这个反应有点失望，因为我觉得我们做得挺好的。然后我们和电视台通了电话。当时是我、格雷格和吉恩在格雷格的办公室里。我不记得电视台那边是谁在通话，对方说，嘿，所以我们有
a chance to read dinner party. Like what a fun script. It was Terry, Terry, what a fun script. And Greg says, Oh, thank you. And, and she goes, it's pretty dark. And Greg goes, Yeah. And doesn't it doesn't say anything else. And then she goes, You know, it's pretty dark. And Greg goes, Yeah. And then she goes, It's pretty dark. And Greg goes, Yeah. Oh, my gosh. And then he goes, Okay, do you have anything else? And then she was so flustered. And she goes, No, he goes, Okay, thanks. And hung else? And then she was so flustered and she goes, no, he goes, okay, thanks and hung up. And Greg just didn't want it.
机会读了《晚宴派对》。真是个有趣的剧本。是特里，特里，真是个有趣的剧本。格雷格说，哦，谢谢。然后她说，挺黑暗的。格雷格说，嗯。然后就没再说什么了。接着她说，你知道的，这挺黑暗的。格雷格说，嗯。然后她又说，这挺黑暗的。格雷格说，嗯。哦，天哪。然后他说，好吧，你还有别的事吗？然后她慌乱了。她说，没有。他说，好吧，谢谢，然后挂了。还有别的事吗？然后她慌乱了，她说，没有，他说，好吧，谢谢，然后挂了。格雷格就是不想。
Like that was the first indication that Greg really liked the script. That like, he just didn't give them any. Yeah, he didn't take the bait. And no conversation. Yeah. He said, oh, like he didn't say like, oh, let us look at it.
就像那是格雷格真的很喜欢这个剧本的第一个迹象。就好像，他什么都没向他们透露。是的，他没有上钩。而且没有进行对话。是的。他说，哦，就像他没有说，哦，让我们看看吧。
We're gonna pull it back. This was at a time where also Greg was arguably the most powerful person at NBC. The office was the biggest show they had. They did not have a lot going on, especially with comedies. Maybe they also had 30 Rock, but he also had Parks and Rec. It was about to get going. So no one could really tell him no.
我们要把它收回。那是在格雷格可以说是NBC最有权势的人的时期。《办公室》是他们手里最大的节目。他们当时没有太多拿得出手的项目，尤其是喜剧。也许他们当时还有《我为喜剧狂》，但他也制作了《公园与游憩》。这个项目也正要起步。所以没有人能真的对他说不。
Wow. Which was great for us. And then the table read of Dinner Party, again, we felt like the script was pretty good and it started in the cold open of Dinner Party. There's some good jokes in it, but like it's a little bit of a slow burn until you get to the actual dinner to the condo. And
哇。这对我们来说太棒了。然后是《晚宴派对》的围读，再次说明，我们觉得剧本挺不错的，而且是从《晚宴派对》的冷开场开始的。里面有些不错的笑话，但直到你真正到达晚宴现场、到达那个公寓之前，它都有点慢热。
I remember sitting there and I was like, Oh my god, like, I thought this was a good script. And like, like, there weren't any laughs for the first few minutes. And I was like, we're gonna get fired. And then the table we just kept building. Yes, my memory and building and it was just like, people can get their lines out. And of course, I wasn't able to enjoy it. But like I was told afterwards that it went well. Also, at the end of it, the table read had gone so well that like the rewrite,
我记得我坐在那里心想，哦，天哪，我还以为这是个好剧本呢。结果前几分钟居然没有任何笑声，当时我想，我们要被炒鱿鱼了。然后围读的氛围就开始不断高涨。是的，我的记忆中就是不断高涨，大家甚至笑得接不上台词。当然，我当时根本无法享受这个过程。但我事后听说效果很好。而且，在围读结束后，围读效果好到甚至不需要重写，
there's basically no rewrite. It's like our first draft is essentially what was shot. And also because like the table read had gone so well, like we all got to leave early. Like usually it's like, the read goes poorly and then you're like, you're going to be there until midnight. And it was like we did got to leave early. Like, usually it's like, Tamarid goes poorly and then you were like, you're going to be there until midnight. And it was like, we did a good job. And so then like, everyone got to leave early, which was very, which was a good feeling. Yeah, the Tamarid was deep. I think my, I don't speak for Lee, but for me, it was like my high point in entertainment.
基本上没有什么重写。我们的初稿基本上就是最终拍摄的内容。而且也因为围读太顺利了，我们全都得以提前下班。通常情况下，围读要是进行得很不顺利，你就会觉得，你得在那里待到半夜。而当时的情况是我们得以提前下班。通常情况下，围读要是进行得很不顺利，你就会觉得，你得在那里待到半夜。而这次就像是，我们干得漂亮。所以然后，大家都得以提前下班，这感觉真的很好。是的，那次围读太震撼了。我觉得，我不代表莉，但对我来说，那是我的娱乐生涯巅峰。
That was like the best moment. I remember I just sweated through my entire shirt. I was I remember I sweated through my entire shirt. I was soaking and by the time in the script when the cops come and Dwight says something to them and he goes, not now Dwight. Like they already knew him on a first name basis and the room erupted. I was as happy, that's probably the happiest other than my daughter being born, probably the happiest I've ever been. Oh, and then the nice thing, I remember Greg said to us, I'll never forget, he goes, how did you do that?
那简直是高光时刻。我记得我整件衬衫都湿透了。我记得我整件衬衫都湿透了。我浑身是汗，当剧本进行到警察来的时候，德怀特对他们说了句话，然后他说，现在别闹，德怀特。就好像他们已经直呼其名了，房间里顿时爆发出一阵欢呼。我当时幸福极了，那可能是我除了女儿出生之外，经历过最幸福的时刻了。哦，然后最棒的是，我记得格雷格对我们说，我永远不会忘记，他说，你们是怎么做到的？
I coming from Greg. Oh yeah. How did you do that was amazing. Yeah, that was the bad we were walking on air. And it was it was, you know, kind of lived off that compliment for months. Oh, yeah. And then we had to stop. That was that was like a big bummer.
这话出自格雷格之口。哦，是的。你们是怎么做到的，这太了不起了。是的，那次我们简直飘飘然了。而且，你知道的，靠着那个赞美撑了好几个月。哦，是的。然后我们就不得不罢工了。那真是一件超级扫兴的事。
Just stop and pick it our own set. We shot like two talking heads and then went on strike. Yes. And picketed our own set. Yeah. You did. I remember. Insane.
不得不停下来去我们自己的片场外抗议。我们拍了两场面对镜头的独白，然后就去罢工了。是的。还在我们自己的片场外抗议。是的。你们真的这么做了。我记得。太疯狂了。
Yeah. Okay. So you guys also wrote Scott's Tots. That's the episode people sometimes can't watch again. Can I just say something? We must discuss. Yes. Go, Gene.
好吧。所以你们俩还写了《斯科特的托茨》。那是人们有时无法再看第二遍的一集。我能说句话吗？我们必须讨论一下。好的。说吧，吉恩。
I just want to shift some of the blame to Paul Lieberstein, who had the idea. Let's just blame him also. We get a lot of a lot of shit. But you know, Paul also had something to do with this. And also, BJ directed it. Yes. He had something to do with this. So I just want other people to also share the blame with us. It's so brilliant. And it has one of my favorite Michael talking heads in it, where says of all the empty promises I've made in my life This one is probably the most generous It's so good and it is you know We've rewatched the whole thing and I don't think it's the cringiest episode
我只想把一部分责任推给保罗·利伯斯坦，是他想出了这个主意。让我们也顺便怪他一下吧。我们挨了很多骂。但你知道，保罗也跟这个脱不了干系。而且，B·J执导的这一集。是的。他也脱不了干系。所以我只是希望其他人也能跟我们一起分担责任。这太绝了。而且里面有我最喜欢的迈克尔面对镜头的独白之一，他在里面说，在我一生中做过的所有空头支票中，这一张可能最慷慨。这太棒了，而且你知道，我们把整部剧重看了一遍，我不认为这是最尴尬的一集。
The one that is hardest for me to watch is Prince Family Paper when Dwight and Michael destroy that lovely family paper. Father and son. Like his granddaughter is the outgoing message, you reach French Family Paper. Yeah, that one does me in. I just think Scott's Tots is amazing. Prince Family Paper is based on, I have it in my sister. What? Yeah, that's based on, that happened to my sister. She was the- What? What? Yeah, that's based on a true story. My sister was working for Walgreens. Walgreens, yeah. And she was in New Orleans.
对我和我来说最难看下去的是《王子家庭纸业》，德怀特和迈克尔毁了那家可爱的纸业公司。父子俩。就像他的孙女是语音信箱的留言，您拨打的是王子家庭纸业。是的，那一集让我整个人都不好了。我只是觉得《斯科特的托茨》太棒了。《王子家庭纸业》是基于，我在我姐姐身上。什么？对，那是以我姐姐为原型的，那发生在我姐姐身上。她是——什么？什么？对，那是根据真实故事改编的。我姐姐当时在沃尔格林工作。沃尔格林，是的。她当时在新奥尔良。
I think she was scouting for a new Walgreens. I don't remember exactly what, but she basically, that was her job, figure out where are there opportunities to put Walgreens. And there was this other drug store and she's like, oh God, this is a place that if a Walgreens went there, we totally put them out of business. And then her rental car, got a flat tire and they helped her change the tire, the family.
我想她当时在为一家新的沃尔格林寻找地址。我不记得具体是什么了，但基本上，那是她的工作，找出哪里有开设沃尔格林的机会。然后有另一家药妆店，她就想，哦天哪，如果沃尔格林开在这里，我们绝对会把他们挤垮的。然后她的租车轮胎爆了，那家人帮她换了轮胎。
Yeah. It's even worse than that. Yeah. I'm pretty, she was so guilty. She still talks about it. And so, yeah, that was what that episode was about. Wow. Wow. Oh, my gosh. Terrible. OK, I also want to talk about Leo and Gino for a second, because so not only did you guys write and direct, but now you're actors on the set.
对。甚至比那还要糟糕。是的。我很确定，她感到无比内疚。她现在还在谈论这件事。所以，是的，那一集就是关于这个的。哇。哇。哦，天哪。太糟糕了。好吧，我还想花点时间聊聊利奥和吉诺，因为不仅你们俩又编剧又导演，现在你们还成了片场里的演员。
And you know there's a deleted scene for the Halloween episode in season two. And it's really sort of the first time you see Leo and Gino. It didn't make it into the episode, you guys, but I want to set it up for you and I want to play the clip. So Michael's getting into the elevator. Leo and Gino are putting a, you know, a big box refrigerator into the elevator,
而且你知道第二季的万圣节有一段被删掉的场景吗。那真的是你第一次看到利奥和吉诺。它没有剪进正片里，伙计们，但我想要为你们做个铺垫，我想播放这段剪辑。所以迈克尔正要走进电梯。利奥和吉诺正把一个大号双门冰箱搬进电梯里，
and they see the camera, and they decide they're going to interact with the camera, and I want you to hear it. Guys, can you take the freight elevator please? Hey, you wanna see a really messy show? You know what? That's my foot. How many are off? Ass, ass, ass, ass, ass, ass, ass, ass, ass, ass, ass.
然后他们看到了摄像机，决定和摄像机互动，我想让你们听听看。伙计们，能用货梯吗？嘿，想看场真正的演出吗？你知道吗？那是我的脚。有几个？屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股，屁股。
Well done guys. How did that not end up in the show? That's kind of fucked up. You want a real show? Follow us. Ass ass ass ass ass. In our defense, we never asked for that. We never wanted this was forced upon us. We were very much against it.
干得好，伙计们。这怎么就没剪进正片里呢？这简直太离谱了。想看真正的演出？跟着我们。屁股屁股屁股屁股屁股。申明一下，我们从来没要求过这个。我们从来不想要这个，这是强加给我们的。我们对此非常反对。
We did not want this. But did you have fun? No, no, no. It's terrifying. I did. Are you kidding? Acting with you guys, that's terrifying. Also, it was every time every time that Leo and Gino came on to set the looks that we would get from, I feel like just from John, no, from, from a bunch of the actors.
我们根本不想演。但你们玩得开心吗？不，不，不。太吓人了。我挺开心的。开什么玩笑？跟你们一起演戏，太吓人了。而且，每次只要利奥和吉诺来到片场，我们收到的那些眼神，我觉得尤其是约翰，不，来自，来自一帮演员的眼神。
I remember John in particular, just being like, I'm in the background of a scene so that we act. Okay, great. Okay, sure. So I always felt, I always felt bad because I wanted to say like, we didn't do this. The other writers did this like we're not campaigning to get Leo and Gino more screen time. We did not want to be acting. The other thing in that ass ass ass scene is I was so terrified. Gene has the line all I have to say is ass because I was I would there's no way I could
我特别记得约翰当时就觉得，我在一个场景的背景里，所以我们要演戏。好吧，太棒了。好吧，当然。所以我一直觉得很内疚，因为我想说，我们没这么做。是其他编剧这么干的，我们并没有去争取让利奥和吉诺获得更多出场时间。我们根本不想演戏。那个“屁股屁股屁股”的场景里另一件让我快吓死的事是，吉恩有句台词，我唯一要做的就是说“屁股”，因为我当时，我根本不可能在那个时候
have remembered anything at that point. And so thank God gene took the line and so all I had to say was ask because I was I would there's no way I could have remembered anything at that point and so thank god Jean took the line and so all I had to say was ask because I could remember that I've since come into my own as an actor but like at the time that was really that was tricky for me. You guys also directed two episodes in season five you directed Michael Scott Paper Company and then in season six you directed The Lover. Can you talk about moving into directing? And particularly with Michael Scott Paper Company, you established Michael Scott Paper Company.
记住任何东西。所以谢天谢尔吉恩接了那句台词，所以我唯一要说的话就是“屁股”，因为我当时，我根本不可能在那个时候记住任何东西，所以谢天谢地吉恩接了那句台词，所以我唯一要说的话就是“屁股”，因为我能记住那个。我后来作为一名演员也逐渐成长了，但在当时，这对我来说确实很棘手。你们俩还在第五季执导了两集，你们执导了《迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司》，然后在第六季你们执导了《情人》。能谈谈转型做导演的经历吗？特别是拍摄《迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司》时，你们一手建立起了迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。
So what was it like to shoot in that tiny room? And did you get to be a part of designing that room? Yeah. Yeah. Well, you know, with directing, the writers were on set for their episodes, and sometimes you're on set for other people's episodes as a writer as well. So we knew our way around the set. We felt very comfortable.
那么在那个极其狭小的房间里拍摄是什么体验？你们有没有参与到那个房间的设计中？对。对。嗯，你知道的，作为导演，编剧们本来就会在片场跟进自己的剧集，而且有时候作为编剧，你也会去跟进其他人的剧集。所以我们对片场轻车熟路。我们感到非常自在。
And, you know, the show had a set look. It wasn't like we were reinventing. Occasionally, a director would come in and, you know, maybe go 10% one way or another. But for the most part, the show had an established look. There wasn't much, you know, probably want to show off a little bit with shots, but there wasn't much of that. But like the the the Wayne Gretzky quote, you know, you miss 100% of shots. That's jeans. Oh, sorry. No, it's not mine. That's Justin Spitzer's. Oh, yeah. There you go. That's amazing. We have to give him credit. That's an amazing joke.
而且，你知道的，这部剧有既定的视觉风格。并不是说我们在重新发明轮子。偶尔会有导演加入进来，你知道的，可能会有10%左右的偏差。但大多数时候，这部剧的视觉风格是固定的。没有太多，你知道的，可能想在镜头上炫耀一下，但那种情况并不多。不过就像韦恩·格 Gretzky的那句名言，你知道的，不射门就会错失100%的进球。那是吉恩的。哦，抱歉。不，不是我的。那是贾斯汀·斯皮策的。哦，是的。原来如此。太棒了。我们必须把功劳归于他。这是一个绝妙的笑话。
Yeah. But that's a thing where, you know, as you start set designing, like, because I just watched that episode the other night, and like the number of times that you see that in shots, like, because the first time you see it, I was like, oh, God, why do people talk about that? You can barely see it. You like, you got a blink
对。但这就是那种情况，你知道的，当你开始进行布景设计时，因为我前几天刚重看了那一集，在镜头里看到它的次数，因为第一次看到时，我还在想，哦天哪，为什么人们总谈论这个？你几乎都看不到它。你必须眨眼
and you miss it. It must have been a screen grab. And then it's like, oh, no, no, that room is so small, you see it a million times. And also the pipes and you're sitting down by the pipes. People are like, oh, it's like in the bathroom upstairs. Yes. That room is brutal. And we got to do a new opening title sequence. That's right. Yes.
然后就错过了。那一定是个截屏。然后结果就是，哦，不，不，那个房间太小了，你在里面看到它无数次。还有管道，你们就坐在管道旁边。大家会说，哦，就像楼上的洗手间一样。是的。那个房间太残酷了。而且我们还制作了一个新的片头字幕序列。没错。是的。
Oh, that's right. And I know you were talking about the fun of Pam and Toby, but my favorite relationship to play, one of those deep cut relationships is Pam and Ryan. There's so many good lines in that. That is one of my absolute favorite runners in our rewatch. Just how much they hate each other. Ryan with the blonde hair. Ryan with the blonde hair. And when he's on the phone and you can just hear all his conversations. And he's like, I don't know, in New York, she'd be a six, but here maybe she's a seven. And then the other guy is my former boss.
哦，没错。我知道你们刚才在聊帕姆和托比的趣事，但我最喜欢演绎的关系，那些冷门关系之一就是帕姆和瑞安。里面有太多精彩的台词了。那绝对是我在重温时最喜欢的连贯笑料之一。他们俩简直恨透了对方。金发的瑞安。金发的瑞安。当他在打电话时，你能听到他所有的对话。他说，我不知道，在纽约她只能算是个六分女，但在这里她也许是个七分。然后另一个家伙是我的前老板。
Yeah, it's so funny. Like, wait, I'm right here. Clearly about me. And then he also, she doesn't wanna like watch him upload his photos anymore because of the topless women. She's like, I don't really want to look at your friend's boobs. And he's like, you know what? You could be hot too if you just made a little effort.
对，太搞笑了。就像，等等，我就在这儿。分明是在说我。然后他还，她不想再看他上传照片了，因为里面有赤裸上身的女性。她说，我真的不想看你朋友的胸部。然后他说，你知道吗？只要你稍微努努力，你也可以变得很性感。
Like, it's just so good. It's so funny. He said that the blonde hair is natural. It's the sun. Yes. She's like, sure. Yeah, sure it is. The sun.
就像，这太棒了。太搞笑了。他说金发是天然的。是太阳晒的。是的。她心想，当然。是的，当然是了。太阳。
OK. He also has a great line in that one. And I know, I mean, Justin Spitzer wrote this episode, but there's that great line in there where, you know, they need to get rid of a person because there's not enough room in there. And so Ryan says, why don't we get rid of the person with the least education?
好吧。他在那一集里也有一句绝妙的台词。我知道，我是说，贾斯汀·斯皮策写了这一集，但里面有句绝妙的台词，你知道的，他们需要裁掉一个人，因为里面空间不够了。于是瑞安说，我们为什么不裁掉那个学历最低的人？
He's such a dick. He's such a dick. He's such a dick. And VJ is so funny. But I remember being in that little room and it was really difficult. I mean, there's a whole scene where we have to talk about the four corners of the room. And you managed to show all the corners. It's very impressive. There's also that amazing moment, Jenna, when you go up to see Idris, try to get your job back and you can't.
他真是个混蛋。他真是个混蛋。他真是个混蛋。而且B·J太搞笑了。但我记得待在那间小房间里真的非常艰难。我的意思是，有一整场戏我们需要讨论房间的四个角落。而你们居然成功把所有角落都拍进去了。这太厉害了。还有那个绝妙的时刻，珍娜，你去找伊德瑞斯，试图把你的工作要回来，但结果却没成功。
And then you're like, well, maybe I can come back as a salesperson. I now have experience doing that. And he's like, no. He I can come back as a salesperson. I now have experience doing that. And he's like, no. He was so good. Oh my gosh. He was really fun. Yeah. Really remember the buzz on the lot
然后你说，好吧，也许我可以作为销售员回来。我现在有这方面的经验了。而他说，不。他我可以作为销售员回来。我现在有这方面的经验了。而他说，不。他太棒了。哦，天哪。他真的太有趣了。是的。真的还记得当他要来、当他来到片场时，片场轰动的情景。
when he was coming, when he was there. Like everyone, all the women were so excited. I'd never seen anything like it. Really made all the men kind of feel like, hey, what the hell? Like everyone was, all the women were, I mean, hey, what the hell? Like everyone was all the women were. I mean, everyone, every female who worked on that show because he was such a charmer.
就像每个人，所有的女性都兴奋不已。我从未见过那样的场面。真的让所有的男士都有点觉得，嘿，搞什么鬼？就像每个人，所有的女性都，我是说，嘿，搞什么鬼？就像每个人，所有的女性都。我是说，每个人，在那个节目里工作的每一个女性，因为他太有魅力了。
He was a charmer. Well, he was like, he would give you compliments. Yes. No, this was even before he came. This was just his arrival before he got there. The idea of the anticipation. The anticipation. Yes. Yes. I also loved, though, that his character Charles was not like won over by Jim. Oh, I should go on. That new dynamic was so fun to watch.
他真的很有魅力。好吧，他总是，他会夸奖你。是的。不，这甚至在他来之前就开始了。这只是他到来之前的降临。那种期待感。期待感。是的。是的。不过我也很喜欢，他的角色查尔斯并没有被吉姆买账。哦，我得继续说下去。那种全新的动态关系看点十足。
Jim wearing the tuxedo on his first day and trying to explain a prank to a guy who has no sense of humor was so good. And then that's also the, Gene, that's the rundown episode. Ah. Where he's like, he doesn't know what a rundown is. Yes.
吉姆第一天穿着燕尾服去上班，试图向一个毫无幽默感的人解释恶作剧，这太棒了。然后这也是那一集，吉恩，那是“汇报总结”的那一集。啊。他在那一集里说，他根本不知道什么是汇报总结。是的。
Yeah. What is a rundown? That is also the episode where, isn't that episode where Mindy keeps coming into Charles's office and saying, Charles, you wanted me? Yes. Yeah. Yeah. And that's also the one where Michael's introducing everyone
对。什么是汇报总结？那也是明迪一直走进查尔斯办公室说“查尔斯，你找我？”的那一集。是的。对。对。而且这也是迈克尔向大家做自我介绍
and gives really personal details. Like so embarrassing. That was also, that's Ellie Kemper's first episode. Yes. Oh yeah. And that has country road where Dwight and Andy are both, Dwight and Andy have now become friends. That dynamic is so funny, but they're both hitting on her in their own ways. And then they start playing country road
并且爆出极其隐私细节的那一集。太尴尬了。那也是埃利·坎珀的第一集。是的。哦，对了。里面还有《乡村路》，德怀特和安迪都在那一集里，德怀特和安迪现在成了朋友。这种动态关系太搞笑了，但他们俩都在用各自的方式向她献殷勤。然后他们开始弹奏《乡村路》
and they're trying to impress her. The end of the scene is the two of them are now just trying to impress each other. And so into playing together that they forget that she's there and she kind of awkwardly like has to get out of the scene is the two of them are now just trying to impress each other and so into playing together that they forget that she's there. And she kind of awkwardly like has to get out of the break room. They're just playing to each other. It's so funny. Toby knocks on the glass.
试图给她留下深刻印象。场景的结尾是他们俩现在只想在彼此面前表现自己，而且弹得如此投入，以至于忘了她的存在，她只能略显尴尬地离开休息室，这个场景是他们俩现在只想在彼此面前表现自己，而且弹得如此投入，以至于忘了她的存在。而她只能略显尴尬地离开休息室。他们只顾着弹给对方听了。太搞笑了。托比敲了敲玻璃。
Yeah, Toby knocks on the glass. Yeah. Can I play a clip from The Lover? Yeah. Yes. This is my favorite scene in The Lover. And it is not when Pam finds out that Michael is dating her mom. That's my favorite scene because you're going no, no, no, no, no, no.
对，托比敲了敲玻璃。是的。我能放一段来自《情人》的剪辑吗？可以。可以。这是我最喜欢《情人》里的一个场景。这并不是帕姆发现迈克尔在和她妈妈约会的那一幕。那是我最喜欢的场景，因为你会大喊不，不，不，不，不，不。
I loved doing that scene. But my personal favorite scene is when Jim finds out that Michael is dating Pam's mother. Here it is. I have recently taken a lover. Well, that's great. Congratulations. Who's the lucky lady? Pam's mom. What? Pam's mom, Helene. Remember from your wedding? You're messing with me. About what? You did not have sex with Pam's mom. Oh, big time. What kind of car does she drive?
我当时演那场戏可太开心了。但我个人最喜欢的场景是吉姆发现迈克尔在和帕姆的母亲约会。就是这里。我最近交了个女朋友。哦，那太棒了。恭喜啊。是谁这么幸运？帕姆的妈妈。什么？帕姆的妈妈，海伦。还记得你们婚礼上那个吗？你在逗我玩吧。逗你什么？你根本没和帕姆的妈妈发生关系。哦，千真万确。她开的是什么车？
She drives a green camera. And the seats go all the way down. All the way down. Oh my god. Oh my god. What? Okay, never tell Pam. And then secondly... Good, a pact. A pact. Although I may have to break it tonight when Helene and I tell Pam over dinner. You alright?
她开一辆绿色的凯美瑞。而且座椅可以完全放倒。完全放倒。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。什么？好吧，绝对不能告诉帕姆。然后第二... 太好了，一言为定。一言为定。不过我今晚可能得打破这个约定，因为海伦和我要在晚宴上把这件事告诉帕姆。你没事吧？
Oh my god. Hey, Jim. Not now, Toby my god. Get the hell out of here, idiot. What can I do? Okay, as far as dinner tonight, cancel that. And please, for both of our sakes, never, ever, ever see her again. I think you're underestimating Pam. I think more than anything she wants me to be happy.
哦，天哪。嘿，吉姆。现在不行，托比，天哪。给老子滚出去，白痴。我能做什么？好吧，至于今晚的晚宴，取消吧。而且求求你，为了我们俩好，永远、永远、永远别再见她了。我觉得你低估了帕姆了。我觉得比起什么来，她更希望我能快乐。
No, not more than anything. Okay, I have a good thing with the mom. Don't call her mom. She's right on my way home from work. Then take a different way home, man. All right. I'll take surface streets. It's the last thing in the world I would want to do is upset Pam.
不，绝不是比起什么来都重要。好吧，我和这位妈妈相处得挺好的。别叫她妈妈。她正好在我下班回家的路上。那就换一条路回家，老兄。好吧。我会走普通街道。我这辈子最不想做的事就是惹帕姆生气。
Okay. So we're good. Yeah. Oh my God. You guys, what's so amazing is that then later, later in season six in the cover-up, which is also your episode that you wrote, it's the last episode you guys wrote for the show, Michael's upset because he thinks
好吧。那我们就说定啦。哦，天哪。伙计们，最神奇的是，后来在第六季的《掩盖》里——这也是你们写的一集，是你们为这部剧写的最后一集——迈克尔很不高兴，因为他觉得
that his new girlfriend might be cheating on him and he's sitting in the kitchen and he's eating the mayo and black olives. Then at that point, Pam is listening, all of the women he's ever dated. And she says, Helene, and Michael goes, Helene. And she goes, Yes, Michael, Helene, my mother that you dated. He's like, Oh, yes, of course, Helene.
他的新女友可能在背叛他，他坐在厨房里吃着蛋黄酱和黑橄榄。然后在那时，帕姆正在盘点他约会过的所有女性。她说了“海伦”，迈克尔说“海伦”。接着她说，“没错，迈克尔，海伦，我那个跟你约会过的母亲。”他回答说：“哦，对，没错，海伦。”
Yes, loved her. And kind of rolls his eyes. It's just, it's such an amazing callback that after all that, Michael has now just forgotten Helene. It's so funny. The lover is, I really, I'm very, very proud of that. And it's like, I mean, also like the, the errand stuff with like Pocoleche.
是的，爱过她。然后还翻了个白眼。这简直，这是一个绝妙的呼应，经历了这一切之后，迈克尔现在居然把海伦给忘得精光了。太搞笑了。致《情人》这一集，我真的、我感到非常非常骄傲。而且就像，我的意思是，还有关于艾瑞尔的那些情节，比如Pocoleche。
Yes. You bring the, what's it called? It's so funny. Yes. You bring the candies back. Yeah. Yes, and she won't put them out until she gets Michael's it called is so funny. Yeah. You bring the candies back. Yeah. Yes. And she won't put them out until she gets Michael's permission.
是的。你把那个叫什么来的糖果带回来了。太搞笑了。是的。你把糖果带回来了。对。是的，而且在得到迈克尔的允许之前，她坚决不肯把糖果摆出来。
Right. Yes. It's some weird turf for it, front reception. Yeah. Well, you guys, that's you guys coming back from vacation. That's a blind guy McSqueezy. Yeah. Yes.
没错。是的。前台那块有些奇怪的地盘。好吧，伙计们，那是你们度假归来的情节。那是“盲人麦克·斯奎齐”。对。是的。
Blind guy McSqueezy. Exactly. So amazing. So in wrapping up about your experience on The Office, when you look back at that time on your life, do you have like a general takeaway or a most prominent memory or something that you take with you from that time?
“盲人麦克·斯奎齐”。没错。太神奇了。所以总结一下你们在《办公室》的经历，当你们回首人生中的那段时光时，你们有没有什么整体的感悟，或者最深刻的记忆，亦或是从那段时光中带走的某种东西？
I mean, for us, this was like film school, you know, because Greg gave the writers so much freedom that we really learned every aspect of how to make something, right? From prepped to meet with department heads to the sound mix. I mean, I don't know what it's like in other shows, but I didn't realize how rare that was to be able to learn all that. And it was five years. It's longer than college. And we were young and those were really formative years all that. And it was five years, it's longer than college. And we were young and those were really formative years for us and I think we became much better writers
我的意思是，对我们来说，这就像是电影学院，你知道的，因为格雷格给了编剧们极大的自由，以至于我们真正学习到了制作一部作品的方方面面，对吧？从前期筹备、与各部门负责人开会到最终的音效混音。我的意思是，我不知道其他剧组是什么样子的，但我以前并没有意识到能够学到这一切是多么难得。而且那是五年。比大学还要长。而且我们当时很年轻，那些对我们来说真的是塑造性极强的时期，而且那是五年，比大学还要长。而且我们当时很年轻，那些对我们来说真的是塑造性极强的时期，我觉得我们成为了好得多的编剧
because of that experience. I think for me too, it just felt alive. Every day felt, it always felt big. We're always a little bit behind. And so you're just kind of coming together and you're just sitting around with like the I mean think about that writers room it's like it's a murderers row of the best comedy writers the last twenty years and just everyday you're just like telling stories and make each other laugh and then all the sudden like you go off and you ever wanna go off to their offices and write talking heads or write a scene and sometimes you read them aloud and you're like, you know, you're praying that your thing
正是因为那段经历。我觉得对我来说，它也充满了生命力。每一天都感觉，总是充满分量。我们总是有点赶不上进度。所以你只是聚在一起，和——我的意思是想想那个编剧室，那简直是过去二十年里最顶尖喜剧编剧的梦幻阵容，每天你就是讲讲故事，逗彼此笑，然后突然间，你可以去他们的办公室写写面对镜头的独白，或者写个场景，有时候你大声朗读出来，然后你会，你知道的，你在祈祷你的点子
is gonna be the thing that gets the biggest laugh. And the show was just kind of at a moment like I remember, I would take the train from New York to Boston for Thanksgiving. And you just like walk like walk back to my seat and or a plane. And it was right when like video iPods started and you just like saw everyone was watching The Office. Like, you literally do it and you'd see like five people would be watching something that you had written like four weeks earlier. And so it was so immediate and I don't know, it was just it was fun. I mean, it was really it was really stressful. I think it was an amazing thing that Greg was able to pull off. Like I felt and I know Jean did and all the writers did,
能成为那个引发最大笑声的点子。而且这部剧当时正处于这样一个时刻，我记得，我会在感恩节时坐火车从纽约去波士顿。然后你就，像是走回自己的座位，或者坐飞机。那是视频iPod刚开始兴起的时期，你会看到所有人都在看《办公室》。真的，你随处走走，就会看到大概有五个人正在看你在大概四周前写下的内容。所以那种反馈是如此即时，我不知道，总之这很有趣。我的意思是，这真的压力山大。我认为这是格雷格能够完成的一件了不起的事情。我当时觉得——我知道吉恩和所有的编剧都是这么觉得的——
you felt like the show was yours. The show was Greg's, but it felt like it was all of ours. The amount of dedication and passion that we all felt for it, and how much we wanted to get it right and do right by you guys and by the fans was huge. It felt like, oh my God, how are we doing the proposal? All of these things, particularly with Jim and Pam, how are we doing the proposal? Like, what, you know, all these things, I mean,
你会觉得这部剧是属于你们的。这部剧是格雷格的，但感觉它属于我们所有人。我们对它倾注的奉献精神和热情，以及我们有多么渴望把它做好，不辜负你们以及粉丝们的期望，这种感觉是巨大的。感觉就像，哦，天哪，我们该怎么拍求婚戏？所有这些事情，尤其是关于吉姆和帕姆的，我们该怎么拍求婚戏？就像，什么，你知道的，所有这些事情，我的意思是，
particularly with Jim and Pam, there was so much of like, we were just like pouring, everyone's just pouring so much of themselves into it. Well, I personally think the best seasons of The Office are seasons two through six. They happen to be the seasons that you guys were on the writing staff. Do it, do it that way. You will. I don't know. I don't know. Exactly.
特别是对吉姆和帕姆而言，里面融入了太多东西，我们就像是把所有人的心血都倾注在其中了。好吧，我个人认为《办公室》最好的几季是第二季到第六季。而这几季恰好是你们在编剧团队的时期。你们自己看着办吧。你们会的。我不知道。我不知道。没错。
Draw the conclusion that you will draw. Yeah. Yeah. This was so wonderful catching up with you guys. You know, we also want to talk about this show that is phenomenal that you worked on and you created Jury Duty. It's so great. And it won a Peabody Award.
你们自己得出结论吧。对。对。能和你们叙旧真是太棒了。你知道的，我们还想聊聊你们制作的那部现象级的精彩作品《陪审义务》。太棒了。而且它还赢得了皮博迪奖。
And you've got a season two. Mm-hmm. Can you share? Can you share anything you want to share about it? Because it is so wonderful. Yeah, so I want to say this show is phenomenal. And it's a documentary, but it's a fake documentary. And there's one real person, and everybody else is an actor.
而且你们还有第二季。嗯哼。你们能分享吗？能分享任何你们想分享的关于它的内容吗？因为它实在太精彩了。对，所以我想说这部剧真的很精彩。它是一部纪录片，但这是一部伪纪录片。里面只有一个真人，其他人都是演员。
Right. And you are documenting a jury duty, a case. There's one person on the jury that isn't in on it. You really follow. And you have James Marsden is also. You guys, I also, I just got my jury summons, by the way, this week. So how are you?
没错。而且你们是在记录一次陪审义务的案件。陪审团里有一个人完全被蒙在鼓里。你们真正地追踪了这一切。而且詹姆斯·马斯登也在里面。伙计们，顺便说一下，我这周刚收到陪审传票。所以你们觉得怎么样？
Because the show was such a huge hit and so many people loved it, how do you do a season two of it? That's been my question. How do you convince another person that they're part of a documentary on jury duty? The second season will not be a jury. Okay.
因为这部剧大获成功，有那么多人喜欢它，你们要怎么拍第二季呢？这一直是我的疑问。你们要怎么说服另一个人让他们相信自己正在参与一部关于陪审义务的纪录片？第二季不会再涉及陪审团了。好吧。
So that's how you do it. No, but I think that, you know, with season one, it was a, there were, I, but I think that, you know, with with with season one, it was a there were I think 4000 people, you know, answered at Craigslist at a Craig's that you guys put. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. And so it's a you know, it's a really involved process. And you know, Todd Shulman, who's one of the executive producers and Dave Burnett is another EP. You know, they've worked a lot in this space. Todd worked for Sasha Baron Cohen for like 15 years. So me, me, Gene, Dave and Todd were like the ones who kind of, we're the beginning of that show.
所以你们是这么办的。不，但我觉得，你知道的，对于第一季来说，这是一个，有，但我认为，对于第一季来说，这是一个，有，当时我想有4000人在你们发布的Craigslist招聘启事上回复了。对。哦，天哪。所以这是一个，你知道的，非常复杂的流程。而且你知道，托德·舒尔曼——他是执行制片人之一——戴夫·伯内特是另一位执行制片人。你知道的，他们在这个领域有很多工作经验。托德曾为萨莎·拜伦·科恩工作了大约15年。所以我和吉恩、戴夫还有托德，我们算是这部剧的元老。
And those guys really had a sense of how to pull one of these things off. I mean, it's wild. And the thing that Todd always said was the idea that anyone would imagine that all of this is fake and all of it is for them is like too much for like the human brain to take. Right. So, you know, it's just there's so much careful
这些人确实深谙如何策划这种恶作剧。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。而且托德常说的一个观点是，任何人如果觉得这一切都是假的、全都是为他一个人设计的，这种想法超出了人类大脑所能承受的极限。没错。所以，你知道的，这里面包含了大量的精心
preparation and rehearsing and casting that goes into it. And you know, so much of it too. It's like, the idea with that show is that you're never punching down. The joke is never at the expense of Ronald. Right. I think that, you know, again, a lot of lessons that were kind of taken from the office, like you root for those characters in Jury Duty. You like that world. You want to see what they're doing week to week. And at the center of it is a really appealing guy who kind of wants to do the right thing, who doesn't want to get, you know, caught
筹备、排练和选角工作。而且你知道，其中很大一部分也是，那部剧的核心理念就是你绝不向下出拳（不欺凌弱者）。这个笑话永远不是以罗纳德为代价的。没错。我觉得，再次说明，很多经验其实都是从《办公室》里汲取来的，比如你在《陪审义务》里会为那些角色加油。你喜欢那个世界。你想看他们周复一周在做些什么。而这一切的中心是一个非常讨喜的家伙，他只想做正确的事，不想卷入
up in the gossip and, you know, forms real friendships. And those friendships were real. Like, that's the, that's kind of the special sauce of the show I think is that the dynamics, like people are playing characters, but the friendships between the actors and Ronald, that was authentic and those friendships have gone on to this day. You're the actor that you cast as the judge and- Ike Barinholt's dad?
八卦之中，并且建立起了真正的友谊。而那些友谊都是真的。我觉得这大概就是这部剧的独家秘方吧，就是那种动态关系，虽然人们在扮演角色，但演员和罗纳德之间的友谊是真实的，而且这份友谊一直延续到了今天。你们选来演法官的那个演员是——艾克·巴林霍尔茨的爸爸？
Yeah, that's Ike Barinholt's dad, Alan. What? Yes. He was a lawyer. Yeah. So we had like courtroom experience, but like all of it, everybody is so convincing and real. It was so brilliant that you came up with the idea that like,
对，那是艾克·巴林霍尔茨的爸爸，艾伦。什么？是的。他以前是个律师。所以我们有那种法庭经验，而且，所有人都那么有说服力、那么真实。你们想出的这个主意简直太天才了，就是：
okay, we're only going to be able to pull this off if there's some reason we have to sequester everyone, which is so great. Because then we got not just courtroom stuff, but we got like behind the scenes stuff. You got, like, behind-the-scenes stuff. Yeah. You guys, it was just a chef's kiss. Well, we are so thrilled for you guys.
好吧，我们只有在有某种原因必须把所有人隔离起来的情况下才能成功做到这一点，这真的太棒了。因为这样一来，我们不仅拍到了法庭上的内容，还拍到了幕后的内容。你们拍到了，比如幕后的内容。是的。伙计们，这简直是神来之笔。好吧，我们为你们感到由衷的高兴。
We're huge fans, so... Will you tell people where they can watch it? Because they can stream it. Yeah, you can stream it on Amazon Prime. Just type in Jury Duty into the search. And when is season two coming out? Uh, I think much like season one, it will just kind of, it will just appear. Okay. Ooh, mystery intrigue. I like it. Just, just checking on Amazon every day.
我们是你们的超级粉丝，所以……能告诉大家去哪里收看吗？因为可以在线观看。对，你可以在亚马逊Prime上观看。在搜索栏里直接输入“Jury Duty”。第二季什么时候上映？呃，我觉得大概会和第一季一样，它就会那么，突然空降。好吧。哦，神秘感和悬念。我喜欢。那就每天刷一刷亚马逊。
Okay. That's all. I will. I will. We're deep in the edit on it now. And I think, uh, I think it's gonna be great. It's really, it's different from season one, but it's very exciting. That is so great. I cannot wait. And then Angela, will you share with everyone why you think of Lee every time you go to bed? Okay.
好吧。就这样。我会的。我会的。我们现在正处于深度剪辑阶段。而且我觉得，呃，我觉得它会非常棒。它和第一季不同，但非常令人兴奋。太棒了。我等不及了。然后安吉拉，你能跟所有人分享一下为什么你每次上床睡觉时都会想起莉吗？好吧。
Well, you know, I got Lee and your wife, you guys designed this duvet cover. And you know, when you have to change a duvet, it's like such a pain in the ass to put the comforter back in it. This is brilliant because you just lay it flat and it all zips in. You just zip in the duvet cover over your comforter.
嗯，你知道的，我和你的妻子，你们俩设计了这个被套。你知道的，当你需要换被套时，把被芯重新塞进去简直烦透了。这个设计太天才了，因为你只需把它铺平，所有的拉链就能合上。你只需要把被套拉上拉链，罩在你的被芯外面就行了。
It's so nice and it's made, it's like got such nice quality and it's got, mine is white with like the little blue stitching. I mean, Lee, I'm your biggest fan of your duvet. I love it. I mean, the natural progression from working on the office, of course, is to start your own bedding company. Yeah.
它非常舒适，而且做工，品质非常好，我的那个是白色的，带有小小的蓝色缝线。我的意思是，莉，我是你被套的头号粉丝。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，从《办公室》转行，自然的下一步当然是创立你自己的床上用品公司。没错。
And so I had an idea to putting on a duvet cover was so annoying. So I came up with what I thought was a good fix. I got a patent. Like during COVID, I partnered up with a woman whose family had a manufacturing plant in Pakistan and we started making samples. And I would like go to dinner parties during COVID, like masked up and like bring like four samples and have people touch fabrics and zippers and all that stuff. And then we launched the company. It's been around for two and a half years now. And we go to newvayhome.com. And we have a
所以我当时有个想法，套被套这事太烦人了。于是我想出了一个我认为不错的解决方案。我申请了专利。在疫情期间，我和一位女士合作，她的家族在巴基斯坦拥有一家制造厂，我们开始制作样品。我会在疫情期间去参加晚宴，戴着口罩，随身带着四种样品，让大家触摸面料和拉链之类的东西。然后我们创立了这家公司。到现在已经运营两年半了。我们可以访问nuvayhome.com。我们有
whole thing. Yeah. So that's why you don't get invited to dinner parties anymore? we have a whole thing. Yeah. So that's why you don't get invited to dinner parties anymore? Well, I think it's a very attractive proposition to show up at someone's house with bedding. Maybe leave it. Maybe it just kind of brings a little, you know. Yeah. Other people were like making bread during the pandemic. You're like showing up with like a duvet cover. I think people thought I completely lost my mind because I was like, they're like, what are you working on? I was like, well, it's interesting you ask.
整套产品。是的。所以这就是你不再被邀请参加晚宴的原因？我们有整套产品。是的。所以这就是你不再被邀请参加晚宴的原因？好吧，我觉得带着床上用品出现在别人家里是一个极具吸引力的提议。也许直接留在那儿。也许它只是带来了一点，你知道的。是的。其他人都在疫情期间烤面包。你却带着一个被套登场。我觉得大家当时都觉得我彻底疯了，因为他们会问，你在搞什么鬼？而我会回答，嗯，问得好。
Basically, and I would show that I would use my hands to demonstrate how the new Bay works instead of working on my scripts. So it was a good procrastination. But Lee, the thing is, is like, when you have a vision for solving a problem that has gone unsolved, how do you ignore that? You can't ignore that.
基本上，我会用双手来演示Nuvay是如何运作的，而不是去写我的剧本。所以这算是一种很好的拖延方式。但莉，关键在于，当你对解决一个尚未解决的问题有着某种愿景时，你怎么能无视它呢？你无法无视它。
Yeah, I agree. You have to follow that thread. Well, I legitimately think that it's all storytelling. And so, yeah, exactly. There was a problem and like, here's the solve and there's a story around it. My wife came up with the tagline, less struggle, more snuggle. It's great. I love it. Yeah. And Gene, have you invented anything, Gene? Oh my god. Um, haven't I invented? Yeah, well, I really feel less And, and Jane, have you invented anything, Jane? Oh my God.
是的，我同意。你必须顺着这条线索探索下去。好吧，我真心觉得这一切都关乎讲故事。所以，是的，没错。这里有个问题，然后这里是解决方案，周围还有一个与之相关的故事。我妻子想出了一个宣传标语，少一点挣扎，多一点依偎。太棒了。我很喜欢。是的。那吉恩，你发明过什么吗，吉恩？哦，天哪。嗯，我发明过吗？好吧，我真的觉得少一点
Um, haven't I invented? Yeah, well, I really feel less than now because I need to come up with some kind of, yeah, it doesn't have to be a home, some kind of industrial masking tape, something that people wouldn't really picture me. Coming up with, like you're going to come up with like the new whiteout, whatever that is. Exactly. Yeah.
嗯，我还没发明出来吗？对，好吧，我现在真的觉得自惭形秽了，因为我得想出某种——对，不一定非得是家居用品，某种工业用的美纹胶带，某种人们绝对不会联想到是我发明的东西。就像你要发明出类似新型修正液之类的东西，随便什么都行。完全正确。对。
My God. Yeah. My God. Yeah. Well, thank you guys so much for taking the time to talk with us today and for always being so supportive of the podcast. We love your episodes. We love you guys and we're here for you. If you ever need a shout out in any way, thank you.
天哪。对。天哪。对。好吧，非常感谢各位今天抽出时间与我们交谈，也感谢你们一直以来对本播客的大力支持。我们非常喜欢你们的节目。我们爱你们，我们会一直是你们的坚强后盾。如果你们以后需要任何形式的宣传，谢谢你们。
Yeah, this was a blast. Thank you guys. This has been great. Thank you guys. I really like going down memory lane. Well, that was a delight. They are so fun. I loved catching up with them.
是的，这次聊得太开心了。谢谢你们。这真的很棒。谢谢你们。我真的很喜欢重温过去的时光。好吧，这真是一场令人愉快的访谈。他们太有趣了。我特别喜欢和他们叙旧。
You know, after we did our interview, they quickly emailed both of us to thank us for having them on the podcast. They're just classy standup fellas. They really are. I just love them so much. And I missed them. Like I realized when we were talking to them
你知道，在我们做完采访后，他们很快就给我们俩发了电子邮件，感谢我们邀请他们上播客。他们真的是既有品位又正直的小伙子。确实如此。我太喜欢他们了。而且我很想念他们。就像我在和他们交谈时意识到的那样
how much I missed them. And I have when we were talking to them how much I missed them. And I have run into Lee Eisenberg several times. We live, I think, kind of close to each other in the same area of Los Angeles. And we hit up some of the same restaurants. But I hadn't seen Jean in so long. Same. Yeah. And you guys, we will put swipe ups to all their things, including Lee and his wife's
我是多么想念他们。而且在和他们聊天时，我也意识到我是多么想念他们。我曾多次偶遇李·艾森伯格（Lee Eisenberg）。我们住在洛杉矶的同一个区域，离得好像挺近的。我们经常光顾一些相同的餐厅。但我已经很久没见吉恩（Gene）了。我也是。对。而且大家注意了，我们会把他们所有作品的链接发在动态里，包括李和他妻子
amazing nuve bed cover. Yeah. And yeah, we hope you have a great week. I just got one. It's wonderful. It's wonderful. It is so soft. I know. And it's really pretty and it's easy to use.
惊艳的 Nuve 床罩。对。还有，嗯，希望你们度过愉快的一周。我刚买了一个。太棒了。真的太棒了。它非常柔软。我知道。而且它真的很漂亮，使用起来也很方便。
It's well made. I love this chapter of his life. I do too. All right, everyone. Thanks for listening. And we will talk to you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey.
它做工精良。我很喜欢他人生的这个新阶段。我也是。好了，各位。谢谢收听。我们下周再聊。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco）。Odyssey 的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼（Jenna Weiss-Berman）和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯（Leah Reese-Dennis）。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔（Chris Basil）进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。